this is crazy video that's come out of
Texas where you've got a bunch of these
parents that are outside this school in
uh you've all
and the cops are actually pinning one
guy down they pepper sprayed some
parents and one woman says that the
police even tased a father who was
trying to get into the school to save
his kids this is a crazy story because
what we're talking about are Texas
parents I'm sure some of them must have
been armed maybe not they were armed
arms Texas parents saying let me go save
my kids and the cops were like no the
cops reportedly went in and saved their
own kids
but there was one woman who breached the
perimeter made it into the school got
her kids out so this is actually
generating controversy on the left and
the right the left is angry with police
they're like what's the point of funding
these police if they're keeping parents
from actually going in and you got
people on the right they were like there
are good guys with guns and the cops
would not let them stop this guy so this
is an interesting story we're gonna talk
about that plus we're going to talk
about some of the stuff going on with
the Sussman trial stuff having to do
with uh russiagate and Hillary Clinton
and uh we're also going to talk about
truth social
plus we got in Oklahoma they they are
now the first state post Roe v Wade I
believe but in recent modern history to
ban abortion from the moment of
conception with limited exceptions which
is really interesting because depending
on which poll you check people are
actually okay with that Oklahoma
basically banned elective abortion now I
wanna I wanna just add something before
we get the show started because uh
joining us of course we've got a couple
really great guests and cash Patel is
here and literally as we're getting
ready to do the show he gets his phone
rings
it says 45 and it says 45 and then he's
sitting here having a conversation with
President Trump and I'm just like get
him on the show dude let's let's do it
so I asked him yeah and he said yeah
we'll make it happen I guess we'll
figure out how to do it Trump's a busy
guy yeah but we'll get there right on
man well so joining us is Cash Patel
how's it going man oh it's going great
I'd love to be back the compound's
looking better than ever man he put some
nice finishing touches on it yeah it's
getting bigger and uh we're actually
building our West Virginia oh you're
doing that okay yeah it's coming it's
it's the materials was hard to get and
so we've just got to build as much as we
can so uh you want to introduce yourself
your your career yeah no yeah try not to
put people to sleep thanks for having me
good to meet Adrian
um great to see you guys again so yeah
so my life exists on fightwithcash.com
fight with cash with a K doing a couple
things since I left the administration I
was the chief of staff for the
Department of Defense I headed up
Trump's counterterrorism programs and uh
did some other stuff along the way
back in the house uh Intel days I ran
the Russia gate investigation for
chairman Nunes put out the Nunes memo
all the Hillary Clinton campaign
financing broke the Steele dossier story
all that stuff and fast forward to John
Durham and Russia gate unraveling and
the Sussman prosecution so I'm looking
forward to talk about all of that but
most importantly I'm very excited about
my new children's book the plot against
the king it is russiagate for children
literally instead of talking about
critical race Theory we came up with our
own CRT we call children's reading time
so basically the plot against the king
is a medieval story with Hillary Clinton
keeper Comey and a Shifty night who are
taken on by a knight named David and a
wizard named Cash on their quest for
truth and of course Joe Biden gave us
the biggest promo ever by calling Trump
the Omega king the day before Donald
Trump launched my book on Truth social
the plot against the king so get it we
want to put in schools everywhere the
Art's fantastic and we're hoping to stay
at number one on not just children's but
he come over on number one it's plot
against the king.com they did um what
did they do like uh testing to find the
slogan for like six months and they
settled on Ultra Maga and all of the
Trump supporters are laughing about it
but what I'm seeing from these leftists
are like they're so dumb polling showed
that people don't like Maga so they're
they're buying into it and I'm like I
don't think these establishment
journalist people are saying this don't
realize
the right doesn't care about that it's
just about having fun and making jokes
so cash thanks for joining us absolutely
we also have Adrian Norman
thanks for having me my intro is far
less exciting than Cash's I'm a
conservative writer author uh
commentator
um I do have a my first book that was
out prior to the 2020 election was
called The Art of the steel it's about
election fraud prior to the 2020
election was supposed to be kind of a
warning
um but yeah I'm happy to be here and
thanks for having me out Tim yeah man
thanks for joining us I appreciate it
what's up everybody I'm also in the
house that was a fun call before Donald
put it down on speaker we got to all
this in a little bit great guy good good
to see you guys too man I'm looking
forward to the show and thanks for the
book cash this is cool looking man I'm
glad you're the wizard we have to be
creative
I am looking forward to reading this
kid's book it seems delightful and I see
and I know that the volume's a little
low so I'm gonna be tweaking that
throughout the show a little bit as we
go thank you guys for joining us this
evening very excited very fun to hear
Donald Trump on the phone so uh we'll
see what the evening has for it in store
for us for moving forward
before we get started my friends head
over to timcast.com and become a member
to help support our work as a member
you'll get access to exclusive members
only segments from this show Monday
through Thursday at 11 p.m we just we do
the timcast after hours show and it's
not family friendly we swear a lot it's
a lot of fun and uh often we talk about
the things that YouTube would not
appreciate and so we were able to have
that Speak Easy and then sometimes it's
just because we want to swear and we're
angry you know so we just we let loose
and if you want to watch that stuff
become a member help support our work
you're also helping support our
infrastructure because we use Rumble
cloud service infrastructure we want to
get away from Big Tech Silicon Valley we
are also
when you become a member you'll be
supporting our efforts to assert timcast
IRL in the mainstream establishment
cultural spaces so we're going to be
doing a whole lot culture jamming as
marketing you may recall that not that
long ago along with the daily wire I was
able to get with their help a billboard
put up in Times Square calling out a
journalist from The Washington Post for
doxing lives of tick tock I'm now going
to shout out what uh has gone up it went
up early but we have
right here a 70-foot billboard in Times
Square so here you can see it 70 foot
billboard and to the left of it is
another screen we're actually getting
two
and it's just an ad for the show this is
how we're starting the idea is I don't
know if Time Square is going to be
actually valuable in terms of marketing
but it is valuable that right above the
ABC News building where all of those
people work is me and at 70 feet tall
advertising this show and so every time
they got for lunch and they come back
and every morning when they come in I'm
above them I'm very happy about that
it's about asserting our presence in
establishment cultural spaces so that we
can basically say you are not the elites
anymore how many of you are able to do
things like this we are we are taking
over we are gonna We are the new media
and it's thanks to all of you as members
are able to do things like this now it's
a bit uh you know uh vanilla I guess
getting an ad so I've been talking with
some other uh trolls and uh smart people
who are good at culture jamming about
campaigns we can do every month that
serve as marketing but are going to
effectively send the message you are not
the elites anymore I'm very excited
about this thank you all so much for uh
supporting the work we do at making this
possible let's jump into this first
story and I'm using The Daily Beast on
purpose because The Daily Beast as you
know is fake news The Daily Beast so
this let me slow down here's the story
cops still can't explain agonizing
hour-long wait to storm Uvaldi classroom
distraught parents can be seen literally
collab into themselves and wailing in
anguish as officers refuse to answer
their pleas to storm the building
we hear about all the time from from
conservatives a good guy with the gun
can stop a bad guy with a gun not when
the police are being bad guys with guns
right when they're using their Authority
and their power to stop you stop a
parent from going and saving their kids
when they went and save their kids one
mother was able to go in and save her
kids now now I want to point this out
I'm using The Daily Beast because they
are fake news The Daily Beast is
certified by newsguard as fake news
proceed with caution this website fails
to adhere to several basic journalistic
standards shocker she I mean honestly it
is because you'd think The Daily Beast
is an establishment Outlet they'd get
cover from everyone and be they were
called real news for a long time no
they're fake news you are fake News
Daily Beast but when even The Daily
Beast fake news is pointing out what was
going on there
and that cops weren't letting people in
we got a weird story I mean some some is
weird I know what you guys think uh so
look I I gotta go to The Daily Beast too
because when I crack the Russian gate
code running the investigation with
chairman Nunes back in 2017-2018 The
Daily Beast outed me as a staffer and
wrote a whole hit piece on me which is
unheard of when you're a staffer you're
not an actual member of Congress you're
just working there and they called me a
genocidal dictator
so I agree with you daily fake news
because I'm not a genocidal dictator I'm
just the son of a man who fled from a
genocidal dictator relation regime
overseas so who's able to get me out
there what dictatorship did he flee from
Idi Amin in Uganda
well yeah why did they actually use the
words genocidal oh yeah and they called
and they called me torque Mata what's
that the guy from the Spanish
Inquisition who was a genocidal dictator
who like slaughtered millions of people
and why because you were calling out
fake news well because I was reporting
that you know we have proven Hillary
Clinton you know paid for it the
campaign we were getting going and it
was big news and they were like we're
going to take this guy out I didn't
think anybody would actually come of it
but then there was there's been a
million pieces after that but they
started well so so what do you guys
think about what was going on with the
with you know these parents this seems
weird to me right well I will point out
some people have said look you don't
want a bunch of angry and Confused
parents rushing into a building it can
get chaotic especially if they're armed
I had a moment of empathy when I was
watching the video and I heard the
screaming parents where it was just like
if I was that and all of a sudden I felt
like because of bureaucracy I don't have
a chance to save my kid and then find
out that the kid was killed is like I
like the cops are doing what they were
instructed to do which is don't let the
people run inside they might get hurt
they might cause more damage
but my god when the when the when it
hits the fan it's like gotta cut it the
rules are off when when your children's
lives are at stake and you need to do
what you got to do to save their lives
that's that was hard yeah I was reading
about this and I was like I literally
cannot imagine what it'd be like to
stand there and think that my kid
literally might die within the next few
seconds if I wasn't to jump in and do
something about it and for the cops to
stand there and to tell me not to go in
I would lose it I wouldn't be able to
would be responsible for my actions yeah
I spoke with somebody earlier who said
that he had had some contacts on the
ground and the reason for the delay is
that they were so the the shooter had
gone into the building and they were
sort of establishing what their
protocols were going to be for for
breaching which is a little different
than this story because now we come to
find out that police actually took the
time to go in and save their own kids
but didn't allow parents to go in to say
theirs or didn't make any real effort to
save anybody else's and I think that's
it's sort of a travesty you know and
this isn't the only situation that we've
had with the school shooting where there
was a huge delay in terms of a police
response you know with Parkland police
were told to stand down there was a long
delay before any action was taken you
got one guy in there with a gun and then
you got what dozens of people outside it
seems like there would be some sort of
protocol in place that would allow them
to be able to go in and and do something
yeah I mean that's the thing with law
enforcement right coming from a law
enforcement background you want your cop
that's what you that's why they say sign
up to go in there not yeah you establish
a perimeter all that stuff but if
there's a school shooting you know get
some bodies in there doing something and
I think that's the biggest complaint you
got to wait for the investigation of to
come out because it's going to take
forever to get everything right but my
biggest question is why went there a
couple cops in there right away that
like why you guys think that cops should
have the armed or not cops rather I'm
sorry
that's not what I meant to ask
teachers teachers do you think the
teachers should be armed in these
schools I think the teachers want to be
armed why not if because obviously
they're going to have to go through some
sort of training you know you can't just
carry
um but if somebody wants to carry if
they're if they've proven that they're
able to be responsible and that they
have demonstrated a certain level of
proficiency with a firearm and they're
able to protect kids you know if they're
carrying concealed nobody's going to
know which teachers are carrying and
which which aren't I'm not I'm not I'm
not for
forcing Any teacher who doesn't want to
carry 2 carry but if you have somebody
who is open to the idea and they want to
be that person and they could be
somebody that interdicts a situation
like this I don't see any reason why we
should not allow that simple answer yes
it's it's not a question of teachers
it's a question of people I think people
should be armed that's it yeah 100 yeah
well I was workshopping this idea
earlier today that I think that the only
way to fix this gun problem that we have
in the U.S is to do it from the ground
up that means cultural change that means
someone who's going into a school or
someone who's going in to rob a store
they don't know if the person they're
about to Rob or the person they're about
to attack is going to be armed and
that's going to significantly dampen
their enthusiasm for doing extremely
criminal activities obviously that's not
something that the government can
enforce and we need to like have serious
respect for guns but I know I hope we
could get there I don't think so so
right now the one thing that really bugs
me about the whole the whole issue is
there's no real conversation uh
particularly from the left on solving
these things they just they complain
about people saying thoughts and prayers
well I don't think thoughts and prayers
are solving any of the problems either
it's just kind of like you know I feel
for you which is it I don't get a
problem with it it's just you know okay
great you know sympathy empathy the left
then comes out and gets angry and says
I'm sorry I'm sorry I gotta stop not the
left the Liberals the left it's like
guns you know leftists or more
revolutionary they like guns the
Liberals are like we need background
checks and I'm like okay we got those
what's next and they're like no no we
need background checks I'm like okay we
have those that already happens what's
next
I don't think you know we hear not from
the right is like we should arm the
teachers that's not going to solve
anything either and I'll tell you why it
may it may prevent because some of these
guys some of these these Psychopaths
might be like a teacher could be armed
that I that I agree with but in this
circumstance cops were there the good
guys with guns were there the parents
were good guys with guns the cops were
and the cops actually impeded it the the
cops were supposed to be the good guys
with guns they stopped it you look at
Parkland that's security guard didn't he
run away he got in trouble for that yeah
so I'm saying
I think we have deep seated cultural
problems where
you know you guys see Beto O'Rourke
hackled yeah Heckle the press conference
on on these kids and and I'm seeing you
know Democrat activists cheer for this
and I'm just like come on man choose
your battles but that's what Beto did is
a contributing factor to why lunatics do
this they know that you're gonna get
Barack Obama that you're gonna get Beto
O'Rourke and they will scream your name
out to the world with your picture
so they that that's what they're
thinking they're thinking this is how
people will finally know who you are
because they're they're sick they're
nuts I think everybody agrees Jordan
Peterson tweeted out earlier that we
should not be saying the names of these
criminals these killers yeah just don't
because that's what the big part of it
is they want to be famous they want it
to be their final Huron and then if they
see names get shouted out that they make
copycats might come up and do the same
thing
as I thought it was a good point
you know some some people have mentioned
what we need is cruel and unusual
punishment for these people and I'm like
well you can't do that under the
Constitution right but this is their
argument is
do something such a way that humiliates
them and makes them not want them well
the dude that ran up on Dave Chappelle
with a knife uh like a gun with a fake
gun with a knife in it yeah they broke
his arms or his hand I mean they that
was cruel and unusual what they did to
that guy well he no you I'd say he had
to come in and deserved it I think I
think you know you run up on stage at a
guy this is a knife you're gonna get
your but your body broken but that's not
that's not cruel and unusual cruel and
unusual is like a stockade you know like
taking somebody second stones at someone
yeah yeah or you know burying them up to
their neck and then having everybody
walk by and piss on him is crawling on
you isn't it if you can if you can like
hold them and secure them then if you
kick them while they're down that's
cruel and unusual this guy no no no no
that's not so uh you can argue cruelty
if it's excessive but aggressive force
is not legal in the case of the guy with
Chappelle I think his arm got dislocated
because they tackled him they like they
all jumped up and pinned him and dropped
on the ground and his arm got messed up
in the scuffle if you attack someone and
someone is using Force to stop you and
you get hurt that's not cruel and
unusual if we capture these people and
then like I said you bury them up to
their neck and dirt and then everyone
can walk over and spit on them that is
cruel and unusual people have argued for
like uh one of the memes that goes
around is is a liberal guy who posted
this or people who post this calling
them like you know tiny PP shooter and
giving them these weird names so that
forever in history they won't be known
by their name but by an insult
I don't know if that actually would work
but I get the idea and I think they're
scratching at the surface of the problem
these people know that every politician
everyone's going to stay there and I'm
not going to say this guy's name I'm not
going to mention them I'm not going to
show his picture
you know but the media does all day
every day and people tweet about them
and that's what they know they get I'm
reminded of the ubliet the uh the
ancient Middle Middle Ages uh punishment
it was just basically a pit and obliet
means to forget and they would take
criminals and they would if they throw
them in the pit and that was it never
mention their name again maybe they got
fed who knows yo that's one way to do it
geez yeah it's hard that was that was
rough yeah I don't think it's coming
back though unfortunately I doubt it
Budweiser would probably sponsor it but
maybe maybe no Sussman in the poop yeah
man let's do it I don't know those
people that that uh January 6th where
there's people in solitary I don't know
if that's really anubl yet but that's
people that's solitary that's basically
it I mean look I was a public defender
back in the day and I argued for some of
the worst people in humanity because
they need to due process and the same
thing it's like okay should you have a
bond shouldn't you have a bond if while
you're waiting trial presumed innocent
and look whatever your political
positions are in January 6 and whether
it should or shouldn't have happened if
you have a 60 year old grandmother who
has never committed a crime in solitary
confinement or not given Bond there's
something wrong with that situation that
means the Judiciary has been politicized
and you're a year on from January 6th
and you have 50 plus people without bond
many in solitary confinement I mean all
that does is
makes them want to plead and get out
plead guilty not have the Constitutional
protections of due process and the
presumption of innocence and the right
to counsel they just want to rack up
political victories I think that's my
interpretation of what this committee's
doing I I think that the January 6
people is as close as you can get to
cruel and unusual with without jumping
over the line in an obvious way keeping
people locked up keeping them in
solitary doing these things is like you
mentioned it's it's effectively
torturing them so you can get them to
just give up that's it and it's all
politically motivated too so it causes
people to not have any faith in the
system which ultimately is bad for the
country as a whole it's terrible I mean
I've argued both sides Federal
prosecutor Federal public defender and
I've just never seen any situation where
you just blatantly Chuck a bunch of
people I've gotten murderers and rapists
out we're charged with those crimes on
bond because it was the actual right
thing to do based on the facts and the
judge made a decision you have people
here with no criminal history who didn't
commit a violent act and they're being
held detained it's I don't know if you
uh uh you you've you've you've been
following a lot of the trials I'd
imagine with January 6. a couple of them
so there were how many have there been
have there been three or have we had
more so far
I think three total trials I got
subpoenaed by the January 6th committee
that's a whole nother story that cost me
a fortune wow um but well so so we did a
segment on here and uh
I mentioned that for the people who just
walked in the front doors that were
opened by the cops how are you going to
charge them how are you going to convict
on trespassing when the cops open the
door and say come on in you know for
people who don't know about trespassing
you got to give a warning if you don't
have a sign in your property that says
no trespassing people can walk on your
property you can tell them to leave but
you got to give them a warning first if
you have a sign you don't need to give
them a warning because the sign the sign
is the warning basically so once then to
the property you've got them on
trespassing the police can issue a
charge
I brought that up
these you know Young Turks for instance
said I was stupid and I was wrong and
then what happens we actually saw a guy
get acquitted exactly on those grounds
yeah because the Capitol building is a
public free space Americans can go in
and out of there foreigners can go in
and out of there literally almost any
time of day it's not trespassing there's
certain areas they can't go to and the
cops are on video opening the doors
yeah those guys need to be interrogated
so when we look at uh
I mean man when you look at what's going
on with what happened in Texas the the
there's nothing that unifies this
country
right so this this thing happens and
what do we get what frustrates me the
most
I see posts from Democrat activists
saying Republicans are spineless and
they won't you know enact gun reform or
things like that they pose there's a
meme going about where they're like ban
the AR-15 and I'm just sitting here like
none of these people have actually
offered up any real any real solutions
they're not interested in having a
conversation about any real solutions
they are Mindless drones saying ban the
AR-15 is it is literally meaningless no
it's like an assault rifle ban or you
know uh or or Shifting the other
conversation from oh that's an automatic
gun America doesn't allow the sale of
Automatic Farms and it doesn't it there
is no there's no it does with tax stamps
right pre-1984 or whatever right no no
but what I mean is okay it's like let's
let's approach it from this point
they've banned the AR-15 oh no and now
everyone's using the AR-10 they've
banned the AR-15 and my M1A or my scar
20s or like come on name a different gun
they exist they're coming out and
they're like they they use this rifle in
many instances with these with these
shootings it's an AR style Rifle right
and so they're saying ban this and I'm
like yo you're just not saying anything
I would like to see a poll of people
what they think AR stands for because I
think a large percentage of Americans
think it means automatic rifle or
assault or assault rifle and it means
ArmaLite rifle which is the company that
created the thing yeah
but they'd have no idea what they're
talking about they don't even Google it
and so what do you get you get David
Hogg right he posts in April like I bet
if I sat down with with my critics we
would agree on things and I tweeted them
politely like hey man come on the show
you know we'd love to have you we'll
cover it they don't respond and so I
tried again he's got no obligation to
respond to me mind you I'm not you know
saying he has to but then he goes on
with Matt Walsh he goes on with
establishment personalities that are
just playing to the same audience
there's no real conversation happening
I look at that and I'm just like how
could anyone believe that the path
forward in this country is going to be
Unity
I just I just don't I can't I can't I
can't see it anytime soon
anytime soon not even anytime late to be
honest
until until we get ripped apart until
we've got English to bond us we've got
the almighty dollar I mean it was
basically a decentralized it's a
unification of states which are all
disunified you could say but unified
under the idea of the Constitution we
all follow the constitution for the most
part constitutional law presides in
every state those are the things that
hold us but our idea is never really
were supposed to be the same or anything
like that even religion you're allowed
to have your own religion but they're
not following the laws anymore
California for instance won't enforce
immigration law and it's actually
granted them an extra congressional seat
and an extra Electoral College vote
because it's by population not citizenry
so when you have States outright defying
the union and federal laws why would any
other state be like okay and now you
know now what do we get we get Oklahoma
being like okay we're going to ban
abortion out right we don't care what
this Supreme Court says that's that's
where we're heading and I I I I I think
it is a uh it is the rule
not the exception that on the right
there's a conversation around policy
issues and the Ben Shapiro will yell
debate me right that's the meme on the
left it's it's the exception they don't
debate and if they try to they have no
idea what they're talking about
well it's fake it that's why you're not
going to get a solution because they
have political epithets that they throw
out on any conversation gun control
abortion whatever immigration drugs
whatever you want to talk about but they
don't have actual Solutions and you're
right on the right they'll at least
debate them and then try to find an
answer like we do for the like we did
under the Trump Administration for the
border for the opioid crisis for illegal
immigration and for things like you know
president Trump actually you know
reformed the criminal justice system
more than any president in modern
American history
and people don't know that you know
because he he a you know Republican
president was the one who did judicial
reform which is crazy it's a crazy
concept because it's not popular on the
right but I thought he was doing the
right thing and I thought it worked but
it gets covered up because no one wants
to talk about those things what do you
do
he did a lot of
this is getting technical but a lot of
alleviations of so when we sentence
people to for drug crimes and they get
sentenced um unequally because of skin
color or ethnic background it sort of
stacks up so you can eliminate those
rules and regulations you can give the
judges more flexibility to reduce those
types of sentences and he basically
undid the Biden 98 uh what's it called
crime bill you know he you you can't
Congress didn't veto it but you take out
a lot of the minimum mandatory sentence
requirements like grandmother gets found
with a gun under her bed that she
doesn't know is there and her nephew put
it there you're going to send her up the
creek for 10 years that's insane it's
insane but it ha it happens I've
defended people that that this happened
to and that's why you can't get any real
actual you know
true judicial reform without Congress
mandatory minimums in my opinion the
stupidest things crazy stupidest thing I
I think you know our Judicial System
needs to be human
it's it's supposed to be judges are
supposed to interpret the law
so you're supposed to have like Grandma
how did you come across that snub nose
and should be like I don't know it's not
mine and they'll be like okay well 10
years well no it should it should it
should be like we're seizing it if you
don't know where it came from and it's
not yours then it's ours now right don't
let it happen again nobody got hurt did
the mandatory minimums come up because
judges were giving people they knew like
low sentences
yeah well they can't unless you unless
you fix the law or unless you give the
judges uh the ability to use this thing
called a safety valve exception in
federal court and they didn't have a lot
of those tools but you also have to
appoint judges who are going to do that
who are going to see the way things that
the the Tim just said exercise judicial
discretion and that was a big part of
the the candidates of not candidates the
appointees that Trump put into the
federal Judiciary is people who exercise
discretion on the criminal side I can't
speak for federal government but I know
that in Illinois the mandatory minimums
on say drug sentencing or or burglary
sentencing was to deter crime so the
idea was that a criminal would find out
that the law was passed no they don't
they don't know they don't care there's
no they know they're going to jail if
they get caught so you end up with crazy
stories I remember one story was about a
teenager who uh his neighbors went out
of town
the neighbors asked this kid their next
door neighbors to keep an eye on the
house the kid knowing they weren't there
broke in the back door using the keys
because he had the keys and he stole a
beer cops driving by saw someone was in
there knowing the people were out of
town went in arrested them and then they
were like this they said about this kid
like okay we don't think he should be
charged with anything severe maybe
trespassing and the D.A was like no no
no there's a there's a mandatory minimum
for burglary he went in the property he
took something he burglarized the
property and so apparently like it was a
it was done it was four years and the
the judge was like I don't want to do
this but it's out of my hands it's
statutory and then the prisons were like
there is no way we are taking a kid who
took a beer to come here and it was this
huge legal battle I don't exactly
remember what happened but this is a
story I heard I think it was like 18
years ago now talking about it in
Illinois that's the problem with these
things anyone can look at that and be
like kid don't take beer from your
neighbors and the neighbors would have
been like oh yeah that's Johnny like
okay we're fine with him taking a couple
bucks courts didn't care they didn't see
it that way those things are dumb so
that was good the the the crime reform
stuff that Trump had done yeah but the
problem is over correction at least in
the law enforcement area in the
Judiciary right drugs become a problem
they overcorrect 20-year minimum
mandatory sentences for if you're caught
with this amount of this or this amount
of that that's a lot of time that most
people like Tim said don't know about
it's an over correction same thing with
um gun control right it it'll get I
think it's going to get to a point where
there'll be an over correction instead
of the right correction because it'll be
political and not the one that people
actually want and it's going to get
messy what do you think would be like
the right correction or a good for well
gun control for gun control I mean look
I'm a big two-way guy I'm all for it but
I think
while I agree that we have background
checks I think our background check
system isn't good it's run by the
government and it's not done the way it
needs to be done I mean that is like the
FBI runs it or ATF or whatever right but
there can be a better system of
screening take another day or two and
build a better algorithm to screen out
people with prior activities prior hits
prior contacts with law enforcement
mental illness issues things like that
people keep saying oh we have background
checks well you can have background
checks if they suck then what's the
point but that's step one do they suck I
mean the first time I went to buy guns
it took I was on a I was on the
mandatory weight I was delayed well
that's that's government I mean sure
that it's putting you on a wait list for
the government to give you a response
that's kind of standard Library I think
there's there's a lot of good intentions
in the background check system yeah I
think reforming it would give you the
exact same results really yeah it's
government man you know there's there's
some things I'm okay with when it comes
to government but I'm like if it's not
working now what can we do to fix it
well I certainly think it's worth
looking at trying to fix for sure
I just think it will devolve you'll
start you'll start off really great and
then after a little while I'll start to
break down but you know I will say this
I'm I'm in favor I I would I would
actually agree I'll I'll kind of you
know simmer down a little bit I think
one of the problems we have with
government is that we create a program
and walk away from it yeah and then what
happens is it starts to fester and rot
if we came back every couple of years
and said let's start it over and
reassess we could actually adapt and if
we're looking at our background checks
through the through the Knicks when you
buy a gun and we're like how is it not
working what can we do to make it work
better and then we just adapt and move
what we're already doing I think we
could maybe we could maybe improve it
for sure let me ask you this so what do
you think the the background checks that
we have right now are missing
data hard data about contacts with law
enforcement and individuals who've had
run-ins with Mental Hospitals and mental
health issues that's one of the biggest
you know things and now that with the
Advent of social media
they're not we're not capturing all the
flags of these guys putting on you know
you can put up whatever you want on
social media well not on Twitter but on
truth you can
um and you can say whatever you want but
if you're out there you know screaming
with guns on social media about
attacking someone that's that's got to
be flagged somehow and that that
algorithm has to be better to capture
that data to give it to the government
to put in that database to screen off of
because every one of these serial uh you
know massacres they all have one
unifying
um connection and that is a mental
health issue of some sort but what sort
of what sort of contact with law
enforcement would you flag as being
justified to remove somebody's
constitutional rights yeah that's a
great question so not just any contact
but if you had contact and the person
was appeared mentally ill then you had
them referred for mental health referral
and balance check then yeah then that
should be when they go to buy a gun I'm
not saying they should be denied I'm
saying that information should be in the
system so someone can go look at it and
say okay should we give this person a
gun let's go check on him let's go pull
all his social media let's go see what
he's been saying that's all I'm not
saying you can't get it but it needs to
be better so it's like a type of red
flag law it's kind of what you yeah I
don't I don't think it works man I don't
know look it's not every so you'd have
to quantify mental illnesses yeah it's
not just any mental illness and then
you've got the issue of you're getting
dangerously close to free speech people
can post things and then what a
background check gives arbitrary
authority to some agency that's unseen
to be like we just think this guy's no
good I I already think it was bad that
when I went to buy a weapon so I we get
we get death threats I mean it's been it
you know we have we have these issues I
want to take care of myself protect
myself I go to the gun store and they're
like fill out the forms they said you're
delayed we'll let you know
why I I am a law-abiding citizen I have
no history of mental illness there's
nothing on my record
but I get delayed now imagine they used
to say they start using people's speech
against them all of a sudden now people
are having their constitutional rights
curtailed but not even their
constitutional rights their god-given
rights to defend themselves from some of
these crazy people from lunatics or just
to keep and bear arms I mean regardless
you have a you know you have a right
regardless of government in my opinion
to do it it gets dangerous when
already there is I think it's the FBI
that does it that does the the national
instant check system or whatever it's
called
it's already bad enough they could deny
you and you don't know why it happened
to James O'Keefe he got put on the list
remember this they just arbitrarily put
him on the list and he couldn't buy a
weapon to file a lawsuit fortunately he
has the support to actually do that
this is why I don't I don't know if
there is actually a solution outside of
cultural issues because we can talk
about all of these things we can we can
do but then you take a look at this dude
in Texas and and he first of all how did
he afford this the thousands I mean
eight thousand dollars in Weaponry
whatever
the money should have been a barrier but
it wasn't then he passes the background
checks
what what could have been done the left
says ban the AR-15 so then he buys an AK
that's not gonna work that you're not
you're not saying anything they say do
background checks he passed a background
check do better background checks and
then what regular people all of a sudden
can't defend themselves look the end
result of what the Democratic position
is I should I shouldn't say the left I
apologize for that because left is like
guns I always got to correct myself they
do they're big on guns the end result is
just ban all guns that is the only thing
and then even that won't work because 3D
printed guns exist and you can make a
gun out of out of a 3D printed material
you don't need much metal other than the
firing pin a thumbtack or something well
even even in addition to that I mean we
already have more guns in this country
than we have people you think all those
people are going to get rid of the guns
because you pass a law now they're going
to lose them in boating I mean you think
everybody with a bump stock turned it in
because the government said nope can't
have it hey and that was strong and
there was one jurisdiction where they
had they they had a thing where you
could return I don't know if it was a
buyback or not but they wanted you to
return in your Bump stocks and the uh
out of the entire city they got seven
wow all right what do you think happened
to all the other ones I heard somebody
on Twitter and they said you know we
need we need gun buybacks we need we
need BuyBacks who's gonna buy them the
government
and they said they said no no they were
like five thousand dollars per gun and I
was like dude do you I'll go to the gun
store and buy a gun for a couple hundred
bucks and then bring it in for five
grand are you nuts I guess I guess their
idea is like yeah then the government
basically buys every gun from every gun
store and there's no guns no then people
start 3D printing them and turning them
in for five grand hey it's ten bucks in
plastic and now I got you know it
doesn't work man but that's the thing
they're already there so all it's gonna
do is create a black market yeah and
then if somebody wants to find a gun
they're gonna find a gun if somebody
wants to kill they're going to find a
way to kill whatever video you gotta
start addressing the cultural the
cultural aspects of this and people's
behavior what's triggering people now
that these young kids want to start
slaughtering their their classmates when
this it hasn't been a precedent in the
United States until what 1999 we've had
guns in the schools and guns and kids
hands since since the 1800s this is a
very recent problem I'm looking at the
pharmaceutical industry and kids on
Klonopin when they're 12 or 14.
Wellbutrin Prozac yeah Adderall Adderall
my gosh Adderall it's an amphetamine and
and then the kids don't know have
emotions they never cried it out when
they were 13 because they couldn't
didn't feel the tear they didn't feel it
and now they're they're lashing out like
wild mindless or emotionless rather
giving kids amphetamines or ssris just
all of this stuff that kids are being
pumped full of
and and I also got to say social media
yeah we we talk about the media aspect
of this how these these shooters think
they're going to get notoriety but it's
also
people I I don't I don't know much about
maybe you guys saw this where people on
Discord were apparently I getting this
guy on
you see this stuff you know I've seen
posts before people like you know do it
you're a loser you won't do it and they
try and egg them on
if that's not helpful it feels like it's
so entrenched like I'm like okay you
could homeschool your kids arm the
teachers and take the kids off of
psychoactive Pharmaceuticals but like
that's like all right Titanic you're
about to hit the iceberg turn left like
it sounds like first of all how in the
hell are you going to do all that the
pharmaceutical industry if it feels like
from my perspective that it's so
entrenched in our in our existence at
this point I don't know how many billion
dollar industry it is and like the way
Pfizer just ran the coveted response
seemingly like they were in charge
somehow a corporation was in charge I I
don't know how to get Pharmaceuticals
out of 12 year olds hands exactly
but I mean it's a scary reality man you
gotta educate the parents but you know
I'd be willing to bet that if you start
talking about the pharmaceutical role
and what's been happening in this
country the dramatic Spike I'd be
willing to bet this Maybe I'm Wrong
there is going to be a visible
correlation between the increase in
medicating children and the increase in
violent outbursts General violence and
maybe mass shootings or things like this
General violence because I think the
drugs are messing kids up
but if you start talking about that you
know that big Pharma is funding all of
these networks they're not going to say
it you know have you ever seen that Meme
where it's like you know local news
brought to you by Pfizer it's like CNN
brought to you by Pfizer and ABC and all
that stuff yeah yeah you're not going to
be on one of these big networks bad
mouthing the pharmaceutical companies
odd because it is I mean it's got to be
the pharmaceutical it's got to be the
drugs it's got to be psychoactive drugs
and the 14 15 year old kids what else I
mean it's driving them insane I don't
know if it has to be I think it plays a
role I think social media plays a huge
role man yeah I think I think it's a
combination of factors but what what
frustrates me the most is that for many
people on the left their only response
is to want to confiscate guns
liberals liberals excuse me liberals is
to to uh to curtail the civil rights to
curtail the constitutional rights of
people who committed no crime at all we
have some so if we're looking at a scale
of things that are reasonable versus not
reasonable it seems that would be very
reasonable to just say why don't we lock
down our schools and have a single point
of entry single point of exit and
security guard that's something very
easy that we could do that's something
that would be incredibly cost effective
given how much money we spend on other
things like 40 million dollars to
Ukraine and every single time we we
propose a Common Sense solution you know
they dig their heels into the ground and
they say no their only answer is gun
control
yeah yeah and and gun control it's just
doesn't do anything I'm really concerned
about I think you mentioned red flag
laws earlier and like if someone has a
medical marijuana card and the
government has it scheduled as a
narcotic it's for some freaking reason
yeah you're you're out if if you get
this is this is this is this is really
messed up if you have a medical
marijuana card you can't you can't get a
gun does it currently stands yeah yeah
and I remember I was in California and I
was I was skating in Venice and there
are these guys that stand outside of
these shops and they're like yo yo we
card we card we card and I'm skating and
the dude goes bro bro come here come
here and I was like I stopped what up
niggles you got your weed card yet and
then I was like I was like what do I
need a weed card for and he's like oh
medical marijuana dude he's like you got
to get medical marijuana man and then I
was like
I don't need it and he goes oh no you
got something we're gonna talk to the
doctor man you don't know until you talk
to the doctor and then I was like I'm
healthy and I got nothing wrong with me
he goes you skateboard your feet hurt
and I was like I mean sometimes like oh
dude you need weed you gotta come and
talk to the doctor five bucks
I got my medical card in San Francisco
and they're like so what's the problem I
was like I'm stressed he's like what's
what's stressing you out is like the
Federal Reserve has a monopoly on our
monetary system and the guy was like
signed he just gave it to me but but now
you can't get a gun well not in
California I don't know maybe not in
California I don't have my license
anymore but I don't know how those laws
work yeah I don't know how absolute it
is it might be like you're a current
user those cards can disqualified yeah
if you have a card do you see what they
do yeah wow and how many how many people
were like oh yeah I'll get a car it's
five bucks I might not use it and boom
now it's like you got to put that in the
form and they're gonna deny you the
background check form you fill out asks
you if you've used drugs so what but not
alcohol doesn't mention alcohol or does
it mention Pharmaceuticals either well
well hold on it does mention alcohol the
good news is there is an exemption okay
if you're Hunter
[Laughter]
you just got to toss your legally
purchased firearm into a dumpster
afterwards yeah so for those that don't
know he lied on his form and then he
what his wife did it or something she
threw it in a garbage can uh dumpster
behind a school yes yeah in school so
insanely illegal oh man and then Joe
Biden comes out and he's like I care
about this like no you don't arrest your
kid and then we'll talk no no Joe Biden
while they while this was going down he
was on another Network giving uh a
speech or something unrelated to this
just just flip the rolls if there was a
school shooting Massacre and Donald
Trump didn't stop everything he was
doing rightly so and shift to the school
shooting stop whatever event he was at
but Joe Biden like you said he doesn't
care he was he was out reading some
teleprompter somewhere while 20 20
children just got murdered if he really
cared you stop and you get your ass down
to Texas and you say I'm here I care he
didn't go to Waukesha he didn't go oh
I'm busy and then what does he do he
comes out and he's like or a deer we're
in a couple words like dude are you
hunting deer with handguns what do you
what do you mean by this there's he's
not he's I'm sorry they're not saying
anything they're not saying this I I I I
I genuinely want the violence to stop I
want I want to solve this okay and so I
am not a gun expert but I know a little
bit more than the average person and I
own several and so having been to the
range having talked with instructors
haven't been giving and given
instruction Having learned about the
laws and having to deal with it myself
I'm like hmm interesting and then every
single liberal that I talk to about this
will say something that makes no sense
like there was that famous news video
that news I think it was CNN I'm not
sure they said fully semi-automatic not
a thing it doesn't yeah they think
silencers are they've never actually
heard he's watched a movie though
they've watched a movie and they think
that they think these things and then
it's just fascinating when I when they
say ban the AR-15 and I'm like
you're not saying anything how do we I
don't know how to solve this man if if
you can't actually engage I made a tweet
about it I said with all of the death
and destruction it's time to do the only
logical thing and Implement gun policy
based on the opinions of people who've
never handled or researched guns that's
right
the Democratic party yeah there you go
all right so I'm glad we solved the
two-way issue tonight yeah
so I just I'm at the point now when they
come out with these emotional attacks or
whatever I'm just like I literally don't
care you're not going to come to me and
I'm I'm tired of playing this and I'm
not going to Pander to anybody I'm not
going to be you know you know what's
really funny is every single time
everyone addresses a school shooter they
go deep into the psychopath it's
deranged person we get it like Ted Cruz
is talking to a journalist and he's like
this this psychotic this psychopath and
I'm like that's what everybody does
and it's predictable they do this but we
all know no one is going to no one in
good faith is going to be like oh Ted
Cruz didn't think the person was crazy
we know these people are crazy we all
get that but it's gonna it's gonna be
tough to find a solution when one party
has no vested interest or no real
interest in actually resolving the issue
they just want gun control so we it's
hard to have an honest conversation
they're never going to come to the table
and accept the fact or publicize the the
fact that 89 of all gun deaths in the
United States are due to gang violence
and suicides yeah you know school
shootings are an incredibly rare event
um gun deaths in general outside of
suicides and gang violence are an
incredibly rare event but but given how
the media covers it you think that we
have a crisis of mass proportions in
these not in the United States even if
you look at it on a per capita basis you
know deaths per 100
000 uh the United States doesn't even
drink in the top ten for for uh mass
shootings yeah and and it's mostly with
handguns most mass shootings are
handguns and we never talk about Chicago
and this is another it's like a cliched
response you'll get from a lot of a lot
of people especially on the right
but I get it it's it you know look kids
dying is is a shock to the system that's
I understand why we talk about that for
sure
but we do have mass shootings all the
time in Chicago in Baltimore in Detroit
in these cities no one seems to care
about them so I guess black lives don't
really matter to them well did you see
that video where the uh the guy walks up
to the hospital where everyone's got the
signs and he says do black lives matter
and they're like yes and he's like what
about the babies that are being aboard
it's like yeah I didn't think so so I
certainly think when they when they call
Candace Owens a white supremacist on
these are not serious people when Larry
Elder is the black face of white
supremacy these are not serious people
yo I would love to solve these problems
and move this country forward but it's
it's seemingly impossible now I I can
I'll fully recognize there are people on
the right who are just as bad oh yeah
but the thought leaders within the right
are having the conversations people like
I'll just shout out Ben Shapiro's got
one of the biggest podcasts in the world
he is a conservative he is a very
mainstream traditional conservative
Orthodox Jew and he is all about having
conversations with people why not have
those conversations some people do
but when we try and invite prominent
people on the left they won't do it they
won't have these conversations and when
I try to engage with them they don't
have the answers they don't have any
proposals that make sense there's
something about the arrogance that we we
see with the establishment Democrats and
don't get me wrong the uniparty
Republicans along with them
where there's almost no interest in
getting anything done let's jump to this
next story though while we're talking
about getting nothing done
this is actually something getting done
actually timcast.com reports Oklahoma
governor signs law Banning abortion from
moment of conception
this is interesting they crafted this
abortion ban off of liberal arguments
leftist arguments they say
House Bill 4327 went into effect
immediately upon signing in bans
abortion unless the procedure is
necessary to save the life of the mother
or as the result of rape sexual assault
or incest that has been reported to law
enforcement removing a miscarried fetus
or ectopic pregnancy will not be
considered abortion there it is every
argument from the left has been
addressed yeah it's brilliant it
basically bans elective abortion
that's it this is the the only state in
the nation to have banned elective
abortion most I I believe there's maybe
like a dozen or two states that have
elective abortion to the point of
viability or at viability meaning the
baby can survive and then you have seven
states plus Washington DC that allow you
to abort a baby at nine months now hold
on I can already hear the the liberal
screaming I did not say it is a common
occurrence that is not my point my point
is it is illegal and so it happens
sometimes
I don't care if it's rare if it's not an
issue and it's not happening all the
time why is it legal why should it be
allowed additionally as for this law
this appears to be the majority opinion
of this country
that people want abortion to be legal
only in certain circumstances
well here it is this is what Oklahoma's
done right
I thought that maybe I'm wrong Rove v
Wade does that not protect or does that
not say that the states cannot ban
abortion it certainly does so how is
this guy signing a bill that bans it the
same way that California doesn't enfor
enforce immigration laws whoa that's
right California status they're a
sanctuary State and they will not
cooperate or work with federal law
enforcement you know I respect the
state's rights to do that I don't know
it's not even about if I agree with it
or not I respect that that's how the
United States works that's pretty cool
yeah I I I absolutely don't I do not you
don't like that Governors can go Rogue I
don't like the governors can go Rogue
they got to because DeSantis man he he
was like a beacon during the covid
pandemic Florida thrived sure there's
differences between Florida being like
we're not going to agree with agree with
federal guidelines on a lot of these
things and we're going to run our state
the way we want there's another thing
when at a federal level when it comes to
things like illegal immigration or
slavery or abortion we're like there are
certain things that this country has not
made that is made illegal now the reason
why I don't like it is if you look at
what California's done
they by by not enforcing immigration law
they inflate their population to a
certain degree and then uh congressional
seats are are apportioned based on
population and electoral college and and
I'll talk about which means California
got an extra vote in the presidency so
when people say illegal immigrants vote
let me correct you they do not
individually go out and vote but it
doesn't matter we elect our president
through the Electoral College they don't
need to vote their presence grants an
extra vote to California California lost
a vote I think in the last uh due to the
last census but before this constantly
just allowing people to come in granting
them free health care they're putting a
strain on on on the surrounding states
and imagine you are you know Nevada
or Idaho or or Arizona and you've got
people going into California
staying there in violation of the law
and then they can cross over from the
from the West into your state that's
already dealing with a border crisis
that's an issue for other states that's
infringing upon those states rights this
is the kind of issue that literally
resulted in the Civil War the South they
had slaves and they said the north
should abide by federal law right well
the federal law had the Fugitive Slave
Act and the north was not abiding by it
I mean I that I agree with that I think
the problem uh I think slavery shouldn't
should have been uh abolished the issue
for the self though was that if the
federal government was not going to be
able to enforce these laws then why
should there be a union at all well
there you go well that's the issue it's
the federal government so you know the
10th Amendment Reserve power States
should be able to do all these things X
Y and Z that are not granted in the
Constitution the federal government so I
think a hybrid of what you guys are
saying is sort of workable the problem
with the sanctuary State staying on the
immigration issue is that it's not being
enforced like the federal government
could go and enforce the law in
California they are electing not to do
that they are electing to break their
own Federal Our Own federal statutes
that's my problem because they agree
with the policy decision in California
that overrides a federal statute someone
should be going to jail on this and
enforcing this law and allowing our
immigration authorities to go in there
and not uh do that but the thing the way
they work it is they basically go into
all the jails when illegal immigrants
come over and make first contact with
law enforcement and the ice detainers
aren't applied they're just like we're
not doing we're we are literally we
California are not doing it it's it's a
it's a federal offense someone should go
prosecute the governor I suppose you
know we can say this too you're just
looking back on my what I literally said
it's an issue of our our personal morals
and World Views as to what we think is
fair and acceptable yeah because weed
for instance California was like it's
legal here and the feds aren't gonna
we're gonna protect you from the Feds
that was basically and then the feds
were like all right they proved their
point we're not messing with California
anymore no that's not true well for the
most part yeah I think that Obama was
like segged in the troops kind of but it
was storming it lasts when I was there
in 2006 it was very it was very
dangerous to have a weed card but then
by 2010 it was very cool there are there
are some instances I suppose I I think
the illegal immigration issue is
probably
what I mostly disagree with and I think
maybe the state's asserting themselves
is probably a good thing so maybe I'll
walk back a little bit
the thing about the illegal immigration
is that it affects the entirety of the
country in a very serious negative way
politically it it actually takes
congressional seats from somewhere else
and gives it to a state so it's almost
like stealing influence whereas the weed
thing isn't that big of a deal and like
I was just saying you know when the
north was refusing to return slaves that
was a good thing the north saying screw
you we don't care about your law okay
that I agree with so maybe there are
positions where the states should say
screw off to the federal government
could the federal government just refuse
to acknowledge the population growth of
California they know that there's
illegal immigration well that's what the
Trump Administration tried to do with uh
with how they're doing the census back
in 2020 they wanted to not include
illegal aliens right so that that's the
whole the whole point of the sense is it
goes to the Electoral College and a
couple other things but that's what he
tried to do that the census was
basically saying you're counting them
wrong you're counting illegal people in
the census in the sense it's supposed to
count Americans because we only have X
amount of electoral votes there's no new
ones it's not like you're getting
another one like Tim said I think what
most people don't get is it's not like
California got A plus one and everybody
else stayed the same somebody lost one
that's the problem that was a matter
that that Trump was trying to take on
he's like why should they lose one if
their game if their population is
remaining the same and another
population is increasing with illegally
uh present individuals that was a that
was a heart of the matter and they
didn't want to like show who was legal
they didn't want people coming in being
like show me your papers because they
thought it was like Nazi Germany and
people would get arrested families get
broken up that's why there's so much
resistance to it yeah I I think that uh
that's a lie I I think they know exactly
what they're doing like California yeah
oh yeah for sure they do and so but
they'll come out and be like it's racist
sure it's easy it's easy to say it right
it's like and it works you know all the
headlines everybody's racist if you're
not for illegal immigration I'm for
legal immigration and I'm just not for
illegal immigrants wrecking our society
what's your ethnic background uh Indian
so you're the Indian face of white
supremacy yeah
yeah I'm Brown lives matter oh yeah yeah
it's it how how do regular people fall
for that stuff right calling Larry Elder
the black face of white supremacy but
it's just easy it's just an easy epithet
that's meaningless and it's like we were
talking about earlier it doesn't solve
anything no one's having actual
conversation they're just like oh that
sounds cool let me go blast it on social
media and get popularity it's used so
much now though that it's lost all of
its meaning yeah I think it's Roman
Supremacy and that we didn't talk about
we talk about Empires and how Empires
fall like the Roman Empire is still so
heavily entrenched the Roman Catholic
Church the Roman and like the Roman I
don't know where else you want to go
with it but why the Romans the Roman
Empire were basically the Vestige of the
Roman Empire right the Roman Catholic
Church is basically the Holy Roman
Empire that lasted for 100 000 years
after the Roman Empire fell apart uh
maybe a little too and then they call it
one derivative I mean if you want to go
back you can keep going back beyond that
and talk about all the other cultures
the Romans were pretty unique in history
like white we talk about white supremacy
is really Roman Supremacy the slave is
state of the Roman Empire I don't agree
I'm seeing a lot of that tonight there
wasn't what's in your water I mean
the Europeans were
you know it's an amalgamation of the
Roman it fractured they all became their
kind of similar but different you know
cultures then we got colonization it's a
really interesting history it's
fascinating the Roman Empire breaks up
then you get all these you know
countries emerge sharing a language in
some ways and not in others then they go
off and colonize other areas compete
with each other going to war it is
pretty crazy yeah they took Germany
France and Spain and Italy the Romans
and then of course the Empire but I I
just think there's a
they're they're there is a majority
privilege right I I think when you look
to any country the people who look
mostly like each other typically are you
know more likely to work with each other
in China they're all racist to people
who aren't Chinese so these things they
happen but
to to blindly just come out when someone
has a legitimate critique or political
concept and to insult them as racist to
call to say simultaneously that only
white people can be racist but Candice
Owens is a white supremacist I'm just
kind of like you lost me because I don't
think you're actually saying words
anymore I think it's just a cult well
I'm not a racist I'm just a genocettle
dictator remember they skipped the races
yeah The Daily Beast said that so you
know I wonder what it feels like to be
called a racist I think do you think
we're all a little racist small R racist
I think that you're right more that it's
more about familiarity bias people
aren't necessarily racist it's just
whatever you've been around my family
first yeah when my family first came
here my dad has eight brothers and
sisters and their wives are husbands and
their kids in one you know one place I
don't know that we were racist but they
didn't know the world they hung out with
Indian people not because they didn't
want to hang out with other people they
just didn't know what the heck to do my
mother were sorry to the grocery store
for 10 years because you know what else
to wear I would like to go on recording
to say I hate everybody equally
so that's smart there you go there you
go let's uh let's let's let's just
totally jump onto a different subject I
want to talk about what's going on with
uh Sussman the Clinton campaign and all
that stuff so we have the story from CNN
and it's from May 17th just something to
kick things off prosecutors say Clinton
campaign lawyer tried to manipulate the
FBI with Trump Russia tip at first
Durham uh as first Durham trial opens so
we've heard a lot about this the the
trial of uh um from you know of Sussman
Michael Sussman do you want to break
down what this is all about what's the
elevator pitch on this story for people
who aren't familiar with what's going on
around all right let me give you the
triangle and and the quick and dirty is
it's all up for free at durhamwatch.com
on fight with cash you could literally
get everything I'm about to tell you all
the documents so you can read them
yourselves all the transcripts all the
judicial pleadings and everything over
at durhamwatch.com but here's a triangle
okay right Democratic party under
Hillary Clinton is running for president
and they're like okay we're gonna do a
couple of things we are going to run two
lines of effort to take out then
candidate Trump we are going to use the
FBI to do it we're going to use the
media to do it and then the Hillary
Clinton is going to be the third piece
of that triangle their campaign so the
Steele dossier we've talked about that
in the show before the hired help from
overseas to filtering unverified
information to the FBI the FBI knowingly
lying to a federal court to surveil
Donald Trump and of course the Hillary
Clinton campaign funded that entire
thing we know that we proved that in the
Russia gate investigation John Durham's
next indictment after this one is the
denchenko case he's trying in the fall
is the Christopher Steele Source the
takedown of that line of effort one line
of effort two was the Hillary Clinton
campaign on a parallel Track Running
let's just call it the alpha Bank server
deal right because it's just easier to
quantify as that that's what sussman's
on trial for
Michael Sussman wasn't one of the head
lawyers for the Hillary Clinton campaign
at this Law Firm Perkins cooey right
Hillary Clinton campaign paid them 50 to
100 million dollars for services they
took that money
and doled it out to people like Fusion
GPS Christopher Steele and the alpha
Bank server this parallel track what are
they doing on this they said okay the
steel dossier route isn't enough we need
a backup so they went out and hired this
Tech Guy Rodney Jaffe okay
and basically said we need you to go
find a connection between Trump and
Russia and here's where we want you to
do get technical get us computer details
that show Trump Tower is connected to
Russia through this bank right so so
they're they're fabricating a narrative
literally and and what's come out in
this trial is is is exactly that the F
the information was taken to the FBI and
the FBI said the next day they knew it
was false that's what the agents
testified to during this case and so
Russia gate should have stopped
immediately well Russia Gates should
have stopped and and but it didn't
because you had a couple of corrupt FBI
cops Comey McCabe strzok this hide guy
who were running the whole thing but not
only were they running it internally
they were running it with the media what
came out in this trial is all these guys
at Michael Sussman Fusion GPS Hillary
Clinton they were all meeting with the
media they were sending Christopher
Steele to meet with the media they were
sending Rodney Jaffer to meet with the
media why circular reporting yeah is
like oh look look what CNN's publishing
must be true we have a source that says
that here's the kicker the whole thing
both Christopher Steele and Rodney Jaffe
FBI sources the entire time and they
both got fired why for leaking to the
media but here's what the FBI did they
kept taking their Intel
to prosecute their case against Donald
Trump once he became president so it is
a it is the biggest criminal Enterprise
in U.S history from my perspective as a
former Federal prosecutor I'm probably
biased because the Russia gate you know
living through that you know running
that investigation but it's a story that
needs to be told and I I think the only
way going to sort of the accountability
portion because you can run
constitutional oversight in Congress and
we got 17 people fired including Comey
and that okay that's a start what John
Durham has done is basically mobilized
this thing and said okay I'm going to
take some people out with indictment so
so the Russia collusion narrative is
false 100 we we learned that with the
end of the Mueller probe right away that
it was a lot of nonsense he said it too
yeah but you uh I think you along with
Devin Nunes you know you you had a
report basically a year before the end
of the Mueller probe I think it was so
we've consistently learned that
something was just which is not true in
all of this but now we actually have in
the investigation that from the get-go
FBI Newt was not true someone a lot of
this information did Hillary Clinton
directly know what they were doing in
terms of fabricating The Narrative and
here's the kicker uh you know just real
quick yes she did or yeah she did she
did but the kicker is we knew it we were
able to prove it with classified
information documents that were coming
in slowly but we couldn't tell the world
what happens now Hillary Clinton's
campaign manager from 2016 Robbie Mook
testifies for the defense in the
assessment prosecution and literally
testifies under oath and says oh yeah
Hillary Clinton not only knew about it
acceded to it and directed us to go and
leak this bogus Intel to the media wow
that's that's the most damning statement
to come out of this trial Watergate on
steroids huh yeah man and it's and I
think the trial wraps up tomorrow and um
you know look the best if people want to
understand Russia gate you need to do
two things go read the Nunes memo which
which we wrote four pages it'll take you
12 minutes take 90 minutes of your life
and go watch the play against the
president is there is there some kind of
like um
how do I describe this
is is there is there is there some
reason why the people who believed this
are the same people who believe Jessie
Smollett
yeah look the one unifying Factor on all
of this the one the one thing that
through the FBI's top level off and
became total partisan hacks was their
unified hatred for Donald Trump that's
what it was it's it is corrupted our law
enforcement industry from just the top
level the main guys they're great but
here's the here's the thing the cast of
characters that read the Hillary Clinton
email investigation the server thing
same FBI agents involved in this case
and the steel dossier Trump derangement
syndrome why do they dislike him so much
that I don't know I mean I honestly I
can't answer that question I have no
idea but it's never been an issue I
served in Democratic Justice departments
the Republican Justice you just did the
mission you're just like this is a job
this is easy this is the fun part go put
bad guys away they were just like nope
King Comey was in there Hillary Clinton
Hillary Clinton uh Clinton and the media
and they were basically like we are
going to take out Trump and then once he
won they were like okay we screwed that
up but we're still gonna take them out
and they continue to bogus do you have
any idea how much taxpayer money it
costs to run these investigations you
have any idea it's it's hundreds of
millions of dollars to do this kind of
surveillance work on a Target it's
insane and it was all it was all bogus
now how much of this is normal politics
do they do this all the time no no this
is crazy I mean this is that fisa Court
the special Court whatever you want to
call it I used to do it to Manhunt
terrorists that's what it's for you know
to protect the nation it's not for a
political campaign to come in and say
we're going to create a national
security issue and oh by the way that
targets my political so why isn't
Hillary Clinton in jail
man proof so look proving that is going
to be very hard that she
um broke a federal law now what you can
do and what John Durham's doing I think
is building a conspiracy case Behind
These indictments because he said in
federal court in writing on his
pleadings he said judge there's a joint
venture conspiracy it's a legal term
what does that mean he's like judge he
said that to the judge oh yeah it's it's
on durhamwatch.com go get the pleading
wow it's his under oath statement
basically that's what a pleading is to a
federal judge and he's saying not only
is Rodney jaffee the tector and The Tech
Guy a target of my investigation but I
am looking at multiple people in the
media I'm in I'm interrogating FBI
agents who worked on this case and also
people on the Hillary Clinton campaign
he can't name those people but he can
give him my title and he's telling the
world I'm conducting a criminal
conspiracy investigation because this
didn't happen with one or two people so
two-part question for you so
what needs to happen in your opinion to
restore faith in these institutions and
then what happens to the country if that
faith in these institutions isn't
restored what happens is what you see a
continuation of what's going on right
now and it doesn't just trickle into
just the political sphere it trickles
into everything when you're talking
about is the FBI doing the work across
the country to reduce crime whatever
type of murder guns Narco trafficking
human trafficking everybody loses faith
in their ability to do those few things
and then we're just completely screwed
but I don't the fix is the man the
Manpower right the whoever runs these
agencies you have to go find that guy
and Chris Ray is definitely not that guy
the guy was running it now he's almost
as bad as call me because he's allowed
this entire thing to go on for four or
five years now and unless you get rid of
these guys but the political leadership
doesn't want to and this is the this is
the problem I have with my doj my former
place of work they always Champion
themselves as being like we're
apolitical we are historically a part we
don't take our orders from the president
well you actually do
and you allowed a presidential political
candidate to give you your orders and to
pay you and to pay for corruption to
take over the top level of the FBI and
you need accountability you need some of
those people to be convicted in federal
court that's a piece of it then you need
to put the right people in place
I'm kind of disillusioned to be honest I
know you know when when the email thing
was going on I love how to you know most
Democrats it's a joke
you know they have a meme where they
amongst themselves will say but her
emails whenever something crazy happens
but her emails and I'm like
dude yeah like someone working in public
office destroyed public records
that's crazy they don't care I know it
like dude if my attitude is I was always
at Trump's not that bad kind of guy like
I didn't vote for him the first time
voted from the second second time
because just Joe Biden was just so awful
and I like to I like the second term
agenda but I was always like very early
on when Trump was running and everyone's
screaming about screaming about him I
was always uh yeah but Trump's not that
bad I mean like this is crazy he's
there's worse than Hitler what are you
talking about calm down dude well I
think the part of the problem people
have is the double standard
um there I read a story about a naval
officer he was on a submarine and took a
photo of where he worked his sub in a
hallway nothing classified just to show
his kid and it got out that he had taken
this photo and because it's it's all
classified they indicted him he was
prosecuted I think he did a little bit
of jail time for one single photo that
wasn't exposing anything sensitive at
all meanwhile you have Hillary Clinton
who had a private server with God knows
how many emails what 30 000 emails on it
and and Not only was all of this
classified information and information
that was born classified on this server
but this server was exposed to other
nations and was and we had
vulnerabilities to work she had
vulnerabilities to where all all of this
documentation was available to to China
to Russia to people who could weaponize
that information against the United
States so when people look at those two
circumstances you got a guy who just
wanted to show a picture to his kid what
did jail time and then this offense and
absolutely nothing is going to happen to
this person it just it it it's it I
could see how the country would be
disillusioned and thinking that we're
basically a Banana Republic where if
you're a certain part of the political
class if you come from a certain
pedigree then you're above the law and
the rest of us just have to to deal with
was it wasn't there some guy who went on
Reddit and he was like I need to figure
out how to delete emails from a VIP do
you know about this story for Hillary
Clinton sir yeah oh yeah there was like
smart literally smashing of servers
there's people like Googling how to
delete stuff there was a guy using
hammers on phones but there was one
story I don't I don't know uh if it's
verified or whatever but someone
apparently this is the story okay so
somebody went on Reddit and said I need
to find a way to remove someone from a
bunch of emails they're very VIP and
then once the like so it was like it was
an Old Post someone found it and they
were like yo I think this is the guy who
works for Hillary who was posting this
so I as an old story I don't know the
full details on but there was tons of
stuff like that the very least the
Smashing cell phones of the hammer yeah
it doesn't do anything it's stupid but
it's funny yeah
emails released to the public through uh
Wikileaks and I read about
um Sydney Blumenthal talking to her like
so many emails between her and Sydney
Blumenthal and his company Osprey Global
Solutions they're like Hillary you know
when we get into Libya we're gonna set
up Osprey to run guns basically for this
new puppet uh government that you're
gonna set up so she's like all right Sid
and she sends it over to her whoever her
manager or assistant or whatever to read
these like so she's basically took us to
war to set her buddy up with an arms
deal I mean but so I read that I was
like well logic dictates I will not vote
for that I don't I no longer support
that maybe it's always been that corrupt
but I mean
there's no sunshine let's let's let's
throw some shade at the media real quick
one of my favorite moments was when I
think it was in the 2016 debates Trump
says Hillary Clinton at acid washed her
server and NBC News issued a fact
checked it yeah saying false Hillary
Clinton did not put a corrosive chemical
on her computer and it was like what
what that's not that's not what Trump
was saying that's got to be the onion
what who did that yeah yeah NBC News
yeah I think it might have been ABC let
me let me but that's that's just a piece
of it that's that's part of the problem
you're saying how do you fix it I forgot
to address it you how I don't know if
you can I don't know what's easier to
fix I think personally I could go in and
fix the FBI in five months I don't know
how you fix the media you guys are the
experts there like how do you get the
ability for five years half the world
and half of America thinks russiagate
and Donald Trump actually colluded with
Russia they are now finally starting to
pull back those stories because of these
prosecutions but how do you stop them
from they they knew the facts back then
they just didn't want to report it check
this out can we pull this up go and get
it it says the claim Trump says Clinton
acid washed her email servers the truth
Clinton's team used an app called
bleachbit she did not use a corrosive
chemical no no NBC News fact check
welcome to the modern media my friends
amazing and that's the problem and how
do you fix that I don't know the answer
to that I don't know how you fix the
media I think that's a harder fix in the
government let's talk about let's talk
about one thing is truth social heck
yeah so uh I have truth social here and
uh this is what my truth social
dashboard looks like so when uh cash got
here you mentioned truth you were like
truthing something I think The Branding
is bad by the way like true thing it I
don't know but you know I just got to be
honest all right I was thinking confirm
could be a good one I'll confirm it and
then how many confirmations did you get
that'd be cool you should just shouted
that out when Trump was on the phone
before the show get better branding I I
heard a great meme they were like Trump
should have called it kafifi everyone
would have wanted the kafifi app like I
gotta get it it would have been Trump's
but uh so so you mentioned you know
getting truth social and I gotta I gotta
be honest engagement is nuts that's
crazy people on Truth social because I
was ragging on it a while ago because it
was like locked up and nobody was using
it Trump wasn't even on it now it's
flowing I went I went and looked at it
and all of a sudden I have like all of
these I posted something nonsensical and
I get all these crazy you know comments
and I start looking at other users and
and seeing this massive engagement that
I didn't see before so before the show
you mentioned I'm like I don't have an
iPhone and you were like just pulled up
on the browser and I was like you can do
that now pulled up on the browser and
there it is now I can use it in my
browser or whatever so
truth social actually has substantial
engagement I mean you were mentioning
you got how many followers 600 000 and
I'm not even 600 000 followers and uh it
was at the same time Elon Musk was
announcing he was going to buy Twitter
truth social spikes in the App Store so
I'll tell you this this seems to be it's
almost like I don't know uh
the snowball rolling down a hill
something that's actually competing with
these big Tech Silicon Valley platforms
what I find interesting is the timing of
Elon Musk wanting to come in and buy
Twitter
at a time when truth social is coming
out and basically getting all of these
Trump supporting populist types to join
the platform if there's one thing that
could potentially stop that it's Elon
Musk coming in pulling Twitter back I
wonder how much of this was Elon
recognizing he said it that people are
leaving too truth social because of the
censorship I wonder if he was like I can
make money if I stop that and bring
these people back you know maybe I mean
I don't know I don't know what's going
to happen on that that Twitter deal but
you know I have to say as a disclosure
I'm a member of the board of directors
for tmtg that owns Street social so no
they don't pay me I just get to do more
work for free but uh but basically what
actually I want to while you have your
picture up Tim so Tim and I I don't
think everybody knows this we are having
a a Times Square billboard off oh yes I
literally have a plot against the king
billboard along with a covidjab
billboard right next to Tim's billboard
but it's mine's only 30 feet not 70 feet
so you won this round but uh we why did
we did it for the same reason we wanted
go into the lion's den and be like why
can't we blast out we last week we did a
whole billboard on russiagate and Durham
watch.com this week we're selling the
book the plot against the king why not
and it's like you said I don't know
that's going to get much you know
generate a lot of business but the point
is we're there oh here's what I want to
point out too when you look at this
image I want you all to understand
here's the billboard okay and you may be
wondering Tim okay you got yourself a
billboard that's cool but like what's
what's culture jamming about it's like
what's it's just got a billboard right
so I talked about how we never spent any
money on marketing for the show until
now and we want to do culture jamming as
marketing ladies and gentlemen this is
above the ABC News building you can see
right here ABC News ESPN with all their
fancy marketing everything and I am on
top
so these many of these blue check
journals most of them probably don't
care some of them are probably fans I
probably like cool yeah but some of
these snooty people these corporate
press these shills on these morning
shows they get to walk in in the morning
and look up and who's on top top of
their building so it is a simple message
to the elites that you are not the
elites anymore these people who think
they're the best that the smartest
they're the strongest no no no we are we
are coming we are asserting ourselves in
the space I was excited for this one I
didn't know it was going to go up so
early it was supposed to go up in four
days but they put it up early so it's
good and that's why we also like gave a
nod to truth social on on one of these
Billboards that we're doing last week or
the next week and um I got to bring up
how we brought uh the beginning of the
show again so yes I did agree and I did
ask president Trump to go on Tim Poole
Tim cast and he did say yes he said it
was the greatest show everyone agrees
you know at least that's what he was
told that's what I said and uh but there
wasn't you know hey there was a bargain
in place I I'm challenging the Tim
casters to go out and buy as many copies
of the plot against the king as they can
because if they push through then I'm
gonna work my tail off to make sure that
Tim Cass with Trump actually happens
that was the quid pro quo yeah that's an
actual quid pro club I'll advertise it
as that oh yeah man where can people buy
it the plot against the king
it's Russia gate for kids how can you
not want to read this story adults
should read this story it's super fun
there's pictures I can read it it's at
my level I got through the first page
already I liked it when you were talking
to Trump I could sort of hear some of it
and I'm like it has to be fake because
it was so perfectly Trump yo man it's
like it sounds like a recording of them
you know like cash comes in here and he
presses playing a video like talking to
I'm not gonna I'm talking to Trump I
swear it now I can get up on your show
just sell books for me and then it's
like just a video that's a quick pro quo
I gotta makeup for 16 years of being
poor in government and educating
children I remember regarding truth it
had a rocky start yeah because they used
Mastodon code but it's what they had to
it was a free software license code I
don't know what they use exactly what
the licensing code was uh but it was
they were supposed to show the the
software code because they were reusing
it as per the code and they didn't and
uh that really bothered me and set me
off but the upside is it's using
Mastodon code which means we can
Federate the thing and create
interoperability between networks so
like if you're logged into mine or truth
social or Twitter if we can get a hold
of Twitter's software licensing codes
um we'll be able to you'll be able to
message someone on Truth social from
your Twitter account and vice versa and
create like a network of networks I
think truth will be a great part of that
this is time to graphene
I'm into that I have some right here
would you like to tie it into graphene I
think everybody's in graphing wiring
everybody's been ragging on Ian because
they're saying morphine is the future
and he's living 20 years in the past
it's the theme it's the structure that's
important not necessarily the carbon
itself although carbon's pretty cool
because if you have this uh hexagonal
lattice structure nanostructure of like
a monoatomic layer of of chemicals
apparently borons equally as cool as
what do you use that for
some dude touch screen wallpaper you can
you can make clothing that's touch
screen super capacitor battery your
clothing can be batteries you're like
you can get Donald we I think Donald can
run on this stuff because this is going
to be the industry of the 21st century
it's going to be the new steel people
are going to be making buildings out of
it uh wiring out of it touch screen all
of this and if he can bring enough
scientists around to create the greatest
graphene like if we can make the
greatest graphene production facility on
Earth in the United States I have an
idea why don't we get when When Donald
Trump devinos myself do a Tim cast live
from one of his properties we have it
sponsored by graphene and we put it on
treat social and then everybody wins
yeah there you go we'll find a company
that makes it I actually need to start
something in the United States that
builds it yo check this out I bought
stock I bought stock in a company that
makes graphene because Ian wouldn't shut
up about it and it's like one of my only
stocks that's still up despite like the
market in 2029 we're going to see Peak
implementation of this stuff you're
going to start but the problem is the
copper industry it doesn't want to lose
their wiring
um so that's going to be a challenge to
disrupt the copper industry but we'll be
able to repurpose the copper I think you
can deposit carbon dioxide I believe
onto copper and create graphene out of
it you can actually put carbon dioxide
out of the air and turn it into graphene
it'll be fine it's like dialed in he is
it'll be really funny it's like we do a
show with Trump and then Ian starts
going off on graphene and then Trump
just gets zoned in and does he's like
tell me more and then just like all of a
sudden Trump's doing pressers he's
speaking and he's running for office and
he's just all about Graphics the future
the new manufacturing the new steel
we're gonna bring all these jobs Ian is
sitting there you know just he retires
because he knows he's done everything
he's can everything he needs to do yeah
nothing will be able to pull carbon
dioxide out of the atmosphere to kind of
balance out the carbon emission type
thing but we're going to have to be
careful that we don't pull too much out
too fast and set up an industry that
sucks it all out because we'll begin
competing with trees we are going to
name you the Ambassador for graphene
let's do it baby we can help a lot of
people or graphene Czar if you can build
a space elevator it's better than the
disinformations are 22 just call me
2024. the the votes come in Ian Gets in
the phone and says I want that position
as Graphics sorry I was promised
I just want to go to space graphing
ballots crap
watermarks well so the original idea I
was like what I wanted to bring up with
truth social was that it's it's allowing
people to maintain their conversations
Twitter was trying to silence people
YouTube's trying to silence people
they're trying to control the narrative
to a degree
where I was talking to this guy we might
have I think we're planning on having
the show his name is Mike Benz and uh he
was explaining how the goal of like
National Security uh officers and things
like this and big Tech is to censor just
enough
so you can make your opponents
politically ineffective but not silenced
because they know that if you censor
people you get bat you get a backlash so
they watch just a little bit just enough
to where they get a head start in the
race truth social is basically cutting
that off people are able to go back on
and follow Trump once again and and
people are posting and sharing what he
says and I'm seeing journalists when
Trump re-truth the words Civil War
mainstream press was forced to talk
about it and that puts truth social
front and center the more he does that
the more they're forced to talk about it
and that's why he's never going back to
Twitter I mean that and the fact that he
owns the company but people keep asking
me that and I'm like no he's not going
back on any other platform he doesn't
want back on YouTube or Twitter or I
don't even know what the other ones are
called but his this is going to be it
it's either you know and I think it's
going to succeed and if you look at the
Bots we were talking about Dean and I
before right Eon what Elon has done is
basically proven the concept that Devin
and I proved on the side of russiagate
is Twitter suppressing free speech and
are there bots the answer to both those
questions was affirmative for sure Elon
has finally put those facts out for the
mainstream media and forced them to take
him on up to 50 Bots that's a lot and
also the freedom of speech depression we
can't get that kind of campaign out but
he's proven that and now they have to
address it now they hate him for it and
now the fact that he said he's voting
Republican I think they've they're going
to come after him pretty hard but if you
can build a company on Truth social that
has 15 million 20 million people you
know by the end of the year or something
like that that's a company that's legit
half as big as Twitter how many users do
you know how many users on truth I know
that I think uh president Trump has like
four million yeah or something like that
so just do some math maybe there's four
to seven on there right now I bet
everybody's following Trump yeah so he's
got 3.1 million followers okay and then
Android engagement is massive take a
look at the New York Times on Twitter
nobody nobody retweets so I can I can
certainly say like I never uh like tweet
at the New York Times there's no
conversation there so when people are
like no one's responding to them like
yeah who cares but nobody's even
retweeting their stories because I do
retweet stories when I see a big story
I'll be like oh you know you know I
basically retweets that I can come back
later and look through the stories that
I was seeing but people don't even do
that for them I just put out I just put
out a truth on the car ride over here
for for my handle at cash for your I was
saying I was coming on Tim on Tim cast
thousands of people in the car ride on
the way over were responding to that
like physically writing and responding
and retruthing and reposting that I was
doing the show and and there was and
there was conversations from both fives
oh I hate you cash I loved him I hate
Tim actually cash sucks and so that's
what you want that's the whole point and
it's human beings engaging on true and
it's fun and the fun the funnest part is
these things called pinata Farms I don't
know if you guys have seen these but
they take real life movies and they
stick your heads on them so there's one
of like me and Trump walking Hillary
Clinton out of a detention center and
it's just built into the platform well
there's a yeah this company has just
built it into this thing and it's now
it's all all over the place and it's for
anything and everything it's hilarious
that's like the beginning of deep fakes
they're gonna people are gonna but you
can't you can tell it's like a joke it's
like an oversized head on like a smaller
box truth social is like JibJab yeah
yeah or the reface that yeah called Fifi
is trending of course I just think truth
is the perfect like it's so trumpian
calling it truth yeah truth is
subjective like what one person believes
is true another person might see
differently and think that it's not true
but we're both looking at the same thing
what was kind of an evolution to we had
the fake news and now we have truth it's
like dark to light it's the yin and the
Yang I love that how they tried using
fake news against Trump and then Trump
turned it around against them and it was
brilliant you are fake news yeah it was
part of it was part of the counter-intel
operation we ran for the last five years
I wanted Joe Biden to go and spend a
half a million dollars coming up with
ultra Maga then I was gonna then I was
gonna have President Trump release my
book on Truth social the plot against
the king the very next day and we've had
the most successful book launch um in I
can't believe they did the ultramaga
thing it's just they they said that the
data shows Middle Middle America like
like Suburban you know people don't like
Maga and so that's why they're going for
it but what they never understood it
just shows they never understood the
Maga people the Trump supporters the
right Trump got memed into office people
were posting jokes they were having a
laugh having a good time the picture you
ever see that picture where Trump is on
a tank it's like a golden tank or
something he's like standing like an
eagle's like it's all funny it's just
like supposed to be crazy or Trump's
face as Rocky Balboa like ripped body
and everything and they think it's real
they're like these Trump people are in a
cult no they're joking I was picturing
them coming out and say Sean on and
being like Ultra Maga and then like the
fireworks shoot out behind them but if
people would love it but then I think
the media like Rachel Maddow would get
afraid because they'd be like oh it's
ultramaga is real like I don't know
because I want to have fun with it it's
hilarious the ultra manga King
hey you know why I don't read the New
York Times why I don't repost New York
Times because I got to pay money to read
their articles whenever I go to a New
York Times article I can't get past the
first paragraph So I just give up on it
and move on I don't read it because I'm
suing them for defamation I'm good but
there you go what did they say uh they
them Politico and a CNN called me
Trump's Ukraine Whisperer and injected
me into an impeachment Fiasco and I said
okay what's that based on like was there
a meeting do you have a witness and if
you remember that clown Fiona Hill came
in and said oh cash Patel Ukraine
Whisperer and then under oath in front
of the world during the impeachment
trial Fiona Hill goes well I've never
met cash he's never spoken and I don't
really know him well then how am I the
the guy so I'm suing them all that's
what fight with cash is all about like
that's my attempt to fix the media is
we're raising money we're actually suing
on behalf of other American citizens
who've been to fame we cut the check for
their lawyers we've been talking about
this all week like you need we need to
take cases that may not win just because
it's the right thing to do you you got
to sue Wikipedia no no I'm on it we
talked about this and if you are it's
the next one
oh okay so I don't have you heard what I
was saying about it in the past few
episodes specifically no I remember our
conversation about it so so I was
talking I was talking to a lawyer
recently and they were like you can't
sue Wikipedia they're protected by
section 230. you can maybe sue the
editors who made the statements and I'm
like let's let's think about this for a
second Wikipedia actually uh do I have
this I have National Firearms Act pulled
up we'll just use this as an example
it says from Wikipedia the free
encyclopedia that's a byline they've
they've asserted it is from them and no
one else so let's talk about how
Wikipedia works if you write on
Wikipedia cash Patel is a lawyer that's
true right or was a lawyer is still
technically but haven't done anything
with it uh is a lawyer yeah that's a
fact statement what if someone then goes
in and edits and changes lawyer to dog
kicker mm-hmm
no one called you a dog kicker the
person who wrote the first sentence
called you a lawyer so you can't sue him
the person who wrote The Single
hyphenated word dog kicker never said
cash Patel is he just wrote one word
well you can't sue him can you
he didn't say anything the first guy
didn't say anything and Wikipedia search
protection under Section 230. that can't
make sense no it does and that's why so
that's literally what fight with
cash.com is doing are we I have a
Wikipedia page that is literally 50
false and so my lawyers got together and
were like no we can actually take them
on then they found a way to do this and
once we go public I'll tell you how we
how we're going to do it but the whole
point is not for me to start suing the
whole point is to get everybody else to
start suing and we've created lawsuits
for other Americans who have been
defamed by crazy Outlets things like
Wikipedia and whatnot and we're going to
keep we're just gonna keep hammering it
that's the whole point that's my attempt
to fix the media I don't know if it's
gonna work is it like class action suits
or is it actual bunch of different
individuals every individual anywhere
can go to the website and literally be
like here's my case summary we'll look
at it for free if there's a cause of
action we're going to March into court
and give you they go to
fightwithcash.com and then sign up to do
that that's awesome yeah nice and it
doesn't cost them anything I mean if
they know Rich donors we always take
those but
um but we I I personally review every
single message that comes in is it a
501c3 yeah oh you know what I'm mostly
mad about is that
uh Wikipedia for a long time claimed I
invented a live streaming Zeppelin that
would be cool which I didn't do and when
I went there and wrote hey this is not
true like remove this they said you
cannot be a source to this article
because you are Temple and you are
biased so we're leaving in that you
invented a zeppelin then I got mad after
a few years they got rid of it and then
I said you know what I'm gonna do it and
so then we built a live streaming
Zeppelin put it up in the air with a
let's go Brandon flag on it and then I
said you know I I didn't go to Wikipedia
But I say to the world okay now that
it's true put it back
I have retroactively made that true and
they won't do it really yeah they won't
put it back they like it's like locked
art imitates life well I don't know
where the original source that it's like
it's funny that it can it can sit there
for years and now I actually did it and
we flew this we got like a ton of views
when we did it too so it was like you
know hundreds of thousands of people saw
it
come on we did it take the video use it
as a source and say Tim did make a live
streaming Zeppelin come on I don't I
don't like Wikipedia I used to be a big
fan I hate him I like the concept it
just doesn't it's too like easy to game
it feels like right now it's too easy on
a fake news I tried to explain Hillary's
emails for instance on Wikipedia I was
like I'll make an edit so that I can
tell people about Sydney's you know
osplay Global Solutions and Osprey
Global Solutions and after I did it
within like eight seconds it was removed
I was like well but that was true
information and now it was it's because
this controls content on Wikipedia
aren't there only a handful of editors
on any page anybody can edit but you can
earn privileges so some people have more
power than others
when you go to high profile accounts
there's going to be a firm that has
editor access that's going to control so
what do you got to do to earn that
access lie a lot yeah it's probably I
don't know how Wikipedia works with it I
think it's like a certain amount of time
and edits made earns you more and more
status or whatever yep a lot of fake
news a lot of lies and it's because the
people who dedicate their time to that
for the most part there's some good
editors and there are a lot of bad
editors and it is companies that are
paid and there's going to be a tendency
towards establishment if that's the case
let's go to super chats my friends if
you have not already would you kindly
smash the like button subscribe to this
channel share the video with all of your
friends and head over to timcast.com
become a member we have a members only
show coming up at 11 p.m or so
let's read what we got here woot do for
you says each of the cops should be
charged with malice murder of a minor
uh
AC yours says this is murder wow Roberto
Lara says the police and politicians
keep proving Michael malice right wow
that one's brutal
yeah Michael Mouse's quote I'm not going
to get it right but he basically said
what is it can you can you say it do you
know it I don't know right off hand it's
like there is no law so obscene that a
police officer would not enforce it up
and including executing children or
something like that yeah soon including
yeah that's bad well yeah true right
just following orders like at some point
the cops you would think or be like this
is just wrong this is wrong we need to
disobey these orders and go in there and
seize I mean if it was war they would
they went in for their kids they're like
I don't care what the my orders are my
kids in there yeah all right Murph tries
says cash are you still going to be
doing a flannel Friday during the summer
months so you know what that's from
right this is hilarious social there's a
q account
whether or not it's the real cue I'm not
going to get into but well me and said
person were uh running around South
Florida and we took a picture of my
sleeve and a beer in front of it and I
we posted a truth that said having it at
Cash having a beer with q
and it turned into flannel Fridays
because I was having this beer and I was
wearing a flannel shirt and now it's
this massive thing on online now the
memes have gotten out of control but
yeah we can do flannel Fridays for you
teams are good yeah
final's nice it's comfy yeah I need a
wonderful Friday James 296 says just a
correction for yesterday's video red
velvet does not not have a specific
flavor but it is a process to make a
cake have a velvet texture upon eating
nice the red is just the food coloring
awesome huh so nobody knows and
chocolate or well if it is uh the
texture then putting it into an ice
cream would completely remove the whole
component of the cake I need to look
into this I just don't like they put all
that food color yeah it's gross why
don't we call it blue velvet yeah you
got to use like beet juice or something
to make it red yeah that'd be better
yeah yeah be used to sweet too isn't it
yeah
Russell
says hey Donald Trump thanks for
watching hope to see you
thanks Tom I'm sure I'm sure what's
watching right now
he's probably watching Tucker or
something is stuck around right now
oh okay well then yeah no all right
Corey Cole says in the case of Civil War
how do you think we would be mobilized
would some sort of conservative leader
arise or we just be fighting against a
sort of government campaign to take
rural areas curious your thoughts I
think it it the the structure of this
country
makes it so that it's very much going to
be like it very much will uh likely be
as the first Civil War was States just
being like yes or no but if you look at
any other civil war it's just disparate
factions fighting in the streets it'll
be you and your house when all of a
sudden someone shows up and you're like
I don't know that is and maybe it'll be
like you'll see an antifa flag or
something or some a variety of leftist
flags and you might just be like okay
they're not my friends yeah no idea
um we mentioned how Robert Rice said
that the states there's going to be a
peaceful divorce effectively because of
abortion issues and I'm like yeah that
is what starts Civil War when a bunch of
states are like we're going to go our
own way and then one group says but we
get those weapons the other side says no
you don't and they fight for them and
then fight for everything
that's how it happens man
Placid Saint says the shooter had a two
thousand dollar rifle with a 700 EOTech
optic down defense rifles and parts are
top-tier gear stuff that I use for my
Gucci SBR rifle where did this kid get
all that money from yeah
somebody hooked him up he said they used
to bully him for his family being poor
and then he has this ridiculous
equipment I don't know really weird
somebody hooked him up that's creepy
yeah
all right
JK
MIT Riley says Tim to be fair there is a
good reason to prevent emotionally armed
people from storming a school with
innocence crossfire-friendly fire Jay
Kermit it's a good point I agree with
that you know yeah I agree with that but
why didn't the police go in yeah exactly
that's the argument
if she was able to go and why didn't the
police themselves just go in and do what
they needed to do to handle business
regarding where that kid got his
Weaponry last night I was thinking about
false flags and getting countries to go
to war for something that didn't
actually happen not that last that
shooting was a false flag but that we
should be on guard for something like
that in the coming years because if they
really want to mobile us mobilize us
into some European conflict or Taiwanese
conflict or whatever and they you see
the the amount like the Gulf of Tonkin
for instance the amount of the amount of
Destruction that people are willing to
wreak in order to get people to support
a war more destruction so be on guard
for that kind of thing and don't jump to
conclusions
yeah Russian China are Masters at it
they do this all the time psyops all day
long and if you don't look out for them
which has to be a priority of an
Administration to catch and assess
through that then we're going to be more
vulnerable
all right man let's uh let's read some
more Bobcat says would you kindly tell
us who is John Galt also AI doesn't
really exist all we have are long lists
of if else statements to be AI it has to
understand the concept of maybe
how do you make maybe Quantum Computing
when it can be a one and a zero at the
same moment
interesting
sanity Clause has stopped sending your
children to these indoctrination camps
no more school shootings no more
indoctrination it's a twofer
forget defund the police defund Public
Schools so on like 2 A.M on the 25th I
tweeted homeschool your kids which was
not a reference to anything at all it
was just like homeschool your kids
because I I've tweeted it before I say
it on the show The Independent took that
and said it was an argument to stop
school shootings and I was like I never
said anything about school shooting that
way I said homeschool your kids Civil
War yeah I I posted a there's a story
about a Norwegian guy I took a bow and
arrow and started shooting people with
it so I posted the story just a
screenshot of it I said nothing I made
no argument and people were like this
argument is dumb to him what you don't
understand is and I was like bro I
didn't make an argument I just posted a
news story man calm down
people are crazy they people are live in
this Bubble World and this is literally
the meme where it's like you can say on
Twitter I like pancakes and they'll be
like why do you hate waffles and you're
like I I didn't say anything about
waffles man I I like waffles too dude
calm down
all right
Gavin deeth says Kindergarten Cop reboot
liberal teacher Pew Pew's little Timmy
for anti-trans statement oh yikes
some people uh yeah I'm not I don't
think I
I don't know of giving teachers guns to
try and solve the problem solve the
problem but I think people should have
guns which would mean teachers would
have guns yeah I thought Adrian you made
a good point that if they want to and
they're trained in it that they probably
should have access to it I mean are you
making the argument that the situation
this week would have turned out wouldn't
have turned out differently had that
teacher in that room been armed
no no I'm saying uh as a direct solution
like walking up to a teacher and being
like here's a gun like get ready to use
it I don't think is is a solution I
think but if a teacher has a background
and they go through training and they
say I would like to carry and there is a
student who comes in with a weapon and
attempts a mass shooting in that
teacher's classroom no I agree with you
are they going to be better or worse off
at the T-shirt they're gonna be better
off with teacher arms what I'm saying is
to approach situation right now like
look at this problem we're facing the
solution is give a teacher a gun I'm
like no no the solution to the problem
is figure out our cultural issues
teachers should be armed and it would
end these situations but you still have
the problem of someone storming into a
school with a weapon yeah it wouldn't
stop them from happening it might be
able to stop them from resolving the way
that it did yeah but two things can be
true at the same time though I think I
think it could deter certain actions but
I think there's also uh adaptivity
you'll just get someone who will conceal
their actions or or Target teachers
first
I think teachers should be armed I think
regular people should be on I think the
two two way exists for a reason I think
the solution is cultural yeah I think if
teachers are armed they're better off I
think the solution is is it some kind of
cultural assessment like we mentioned
drugs and social media addictions and
manipulation I think mostly the drugs to
be honest I think that stuff's warping
kids Minds
that and weird groomers on the internet
that's true too
all right Matthew reckhamp says to quote
Stephen Crowder what do you think would
be more effective at stopping a school
shooter a sign with a picture of a gun
with a line over it or a turret
a turret well hold on hold on definitely
in some circumstances you could beat the
guy with the sign yeah two all right
yeah yeah that's actually a man you know
you can't do those kind of jokes on
YouTube but I think you know I'm into
the dark comedy where it's like racist
no no no just like stopping a school
shooting by someone taking us a gun-free
zone sign and beating the perpetrator
with it to stop them so it's like what
do I do and it's like this will work you
gotta turned into a cartoon then it'll
be totally acceptable Sheamus yeah
I don't know if Sheamus want to do that
that one's a little too dark
all right Dakota dad says you're going
to need an army to stop me from getting
my kids I will stop at absolutely
nothing and run through I don't care who
to make uh I don't care who to make sure
they're okay that's right you see that
video of the guy running into the Barney
building to save his dog yeah no this is
crazy the fires in have you guys ever
been next to a burning building no
actually it's hot it's hot it's and
that's an understatement people don't
get this because you see a fire you've
maybe been around a campfire and you're
thinking like oh okay
you can't so when I was in Ferguson and
they they burned all those buildings on
West Florissant driving in the car
in the car with with the air run and
everything when you drive past these
buildings that are maybe even 50 to 100
feet away it feels like there's a
campfire right in front of your face
that's the the heat is so intense so
when you walk up it's unbearable to even
walk up to the building this dude runs
in to get his dog into the firefighters
like dude what he comes out his legs are
like burned up love it yeah he's not
gonna leave his dog in there man now
imagine what's going to be like if your
kids
are in a building with the shooter
this guy his dad got tasered like dude
worth it
I'm crazy man
all right salty duckling says cash since
you got 45's number please push him to
abolish the ATF when he wins in 24.
that's it's a thought we'll think about
it it's just another Federal agency
doing work that other federal agencies
already do it's an over correction I
made a tweet and I trolled mostly I
guess I'm mostly conservatives it's
funny though the gun people liked it I
said let me let me just I'll just read
what I said I said did you know the
National Firearms Act codified a path to
owning silencers and automatic rifles
repeal the NFA now spineless GOP won't
do it call your member of Congress and
tell them repeal the NFA now that's true
and a whole all that is true amazing
spineless GOP won't repeal the NFL
that's true it did codify a path to
owning silencers and automatic rifles
restricting access to them but still
codifying a path to get it
and like it was funny because the gun
people my favorite response was dude if
this works
like all the Liberals being like yeah I
repealed the NFA but a bunch of
conservatives were like you're wrong on
this one Tim also it's not called a
silencer it's a suppressor and I'm just
like
you're missing everything right over
their heads right overheads let's uh
read some more Super chats I got your
back all right let's grab some more
Andy Welsh says check out the magic card
for ubliet it's perfect is that he
pronounce it was it yeah
MTG dungeon it's like a skeleton what
does it do remove remove a creature from
the game from the game until the Ubly
that's removed from play I believe uh
it's an old card from Arabian Nights
really yeah I believe it's they've
remade that card so many times whenublia
enters the battlefield tart creature
phases out until ublia leaves the battle
oh you know yo Ian I gotta tell you
funny story and so this guy I was
tweeting right and this guy's tweeting
at me like telling me I'm wrong and all
this stuff about politics and then it
turns out in his profile he plays magic
so I so I tweeted at him my Kiki geeky
deck would obliterate you and he said
doubt can you believe it that's love
doubt no way obliterate and it's not
your faulty
have like 99 of people are like we have
no idea what they just said yeah we're
talking about a strategy card familiar
and I'm making a joke there you go let's
read some more Super chats it's funny
because it was true it's funny because
someone thought they could beat my
commander deck never gonna happen it is
it is a it is a crazy day all right
kalish nickov kalash nickov and what is
that I'm a God-fearing conservative but
if you gave me a Thin Blue Line flag and
a pride flag a box of matches and a cup
of gasoline The Thin Blue Line is
getting torched first huh whoa mood
first though remember that video where
they were throwing the flag on the
ground stomping on it
people are not happy man
all right
Ben Hickson says if Americans give up
their guns then they will have unarmed
protesters being shot with rubber
bullets by a war memorial after being in
lockdown for over 200 days watch
Battleground Melbourne on YouTube for
the recount wow
so I tweeted I'm gonna buy more guns and
then someone responded they were like
as an Australian I'm curious why do you
need more guns and someone responded so
that we don't get sent to quarantine
camps when we get a sickness with a 99.8
survival rate or something like that and
then people started quoting and posting
it
William Andrews says live in Maryland
with my anti-gun wife who found my rifle
and armor I said if bad guys have this
then I will too think of our kids went
pretty well that's fair nice
oh yeah
John esch says my sister is a socialist
and she's arguing with me about guns and
taxes I'm a Libertarian believing in
individual responsibility and personal
responsibility please say why gun laws
don't work so most of the leftists
including socialists are pro-gun there
is they so the Socialist Rifle
Association is a leftist pro-gun
organization if you are claiming to be a
leftist and you are not your anti-gun
you are not a leftist because Karl Marx
said
under no pretext that's right should the
workers surrender arms and ammunition
all efforts should be I'm paraphrasing
next I don't Know full quote should be
frustrated by force if necessary that's
Karl Marx I agree fully do not give up
your weapons so you should definitely
look into that quote from Karl Marx
because he said it outright gun laws
don't work for several reasons in
Maryland they they've banned the M1A for
instance
they have not banned the scar 20s okay
the star 20s is a modern 308 and the M1A
is a much older model it's like it makes
no sense why they would do that
they've when people come out and say
things like ban the AR-15
it's like okay well have you ever
watched slugfest KSG 25 with many many
shells or whatever and they have like 41
shells in this pump action shotgun
these people don't know what they're
talking about you would have to outright
ban all guns and then you have to
contend with 3D printed guns which can
be fully plastic except for the firing
pin and I'm probably wrong about that
too because they've probably got
advancements at this point that I don't
even know about
so people can buy 3D printer for 300
bucks buy some materials and just print
a gun yeah what are you gonna ban it's
not working guns exist
in in the Netherlands in Europe they
have a 3D printed gun issue where people
are just printing them
good luck they got a Grenade problem in
Sweden from the um I can't remember
there was a what was it um
the Balkan the uh I don't know they have
grenades right there's like some
Organization no no there was like a war
yeah it was the Balkan Wars or whatever
Eastern European something like that
there's grenades all over the place
those are illegal
murder is illegal yeah people still
doing it that's crazy criminals don't
respect the law that's also crazy why
that's that's that's wrong they should
they should make it illegal yeah yeah
they should make murder illegal maybe
that'll stop it being criminal illegal
all right the great treasure says long
time listener first time caller when you
get president Trump on you should
definitely record the entire show for
your website so when YouTube inevitably
inevitably deletes it we can still see
it we love you in Wisconsin that is the
plan as always and
um I don't know maybe we do it on rumble
or something yeah probably if YouTube
does not want our business
I I respect their decision and it'll be
our biggest show ever but if YouTube
wants to say to us like
look if YouTube comes to me and says
look we don't want you to interview
Trump and have a massive show then I'll
say hey no problem guys we'll do it on
Rumble that's cool that's why it's so
important to have these Alternatives
that's why we use Rumble infrastructure
for our website so that we can make sure
YouTube knows hey nope nope no problem
no beef we'll go use the other platform
where they'll get all the traffic and
the views and make all the money that's
cool you guys if you don't want to be
culturally relevant that's fine that's
fine
all right
Charles Kinsey says hey Tim how do you
feel about making a commercial with
veterans and ex-cops asking the parents
to let us protect our children and
precious and precious resource
I don't know I guess I feel neutrally
about it I'm not sure what what the
intent is or you know seems sounds cool
Maybe
Carl Ashby says Tim check out the
shooting in Charleston West Virginia
last night armed party goer shoots and
kills active shooter no one else harmed
wow in Charleston that's that's not that
far away
it's decently far away from us but you
know relatively close
crazy did you look it up yeah I'm
looking at it now I haven't seen
anything yet this is why you don't mess
around in West Virginia it's a
constitutional carry state which the
crazy thing is Texas is now too but
maybe Texas hasn't been constitutional
Carry long enough looks like shooting
victim pulled an assault rifle at a
party and then that's what it says from
msn.com yeah it's what is that assault
rifle what is it a 50 BMG at a party he
could have a 916 you know an NFA select
fire rifle that was the headline the
vague headline and then uh one has been
detained from that woman stops gun
minute party so maybe as a girl Brad
matsuzak maduzak says can you get Steve
Kerr on and dunk on him please Steve you
recently came out and said you want the
the the the uh Congress to pass hr8 to
create background checks
we already have background checks dude
so unless you are talking about
reforming like cash did just being like
why don't they pass background checks
because we already did
ah it's so frustrating every time I go
and I gotta fill out that stupid form
because these people have no idea what
they're talking about
I love it when I went to the March for
our lives there are people saying things
like ban fully automatic weapons and I
was like
so I would ask them I'm like so you you
do know that for the most part they have
been like you can't get a new one and
you need special privileges I'm like oh
really and I'm like do you know what
you're protesting I met one guy who knew
he was protesting and we had a good
conversation about I was like okay well
this guy was talking about he's got bad
opinions I don't know I don't like his
opinions he's got him but at least he
was informed but almost all of them were
saying holding up signs that were like
meaningless where
they're like we want background checks
now and I'm like
and then they talk about the Gun Show
loophole but I'm like have you ever been
to a gun show and tried to get a firearm
like every every uh seller has a little
kiosk set up where they still run you
through the next system even in a gun
show yep
it's all loophole what they're talking
about is that in West Virginia you can
sell to a family member
and that you assume responsibility if
they have certain issues or you assume
liability so if you know Cletus wants to
sell a rifle to Billy job in the
mountains in you know five hours from
civilization because there's a bear
problem or something no no no they've
got they've got a drive to an FFL in a
major city and then do the transfer
there
so that's what they're talking about I I
don't think that's what they're talking
about that's not a good faith argument
that makes no sense they just don't know
that we already have the Nyx system
there you go
American Gun chick says Cash's solution
of using social media posts to determine
someone's eligibility for their second
amendment rights sounds like the start
to a social credit score that's a hard
no for me dog
[Laughter]
I guess you're not buying a book
say that
plot against the king
yeah I'm kind of with that person and
that was what I was just thinking about
is pre-thought pre-crime that whole
thing of Life did you think a violent
thought when you were nine well let's
check the records of the neural net yes
you're no longer access to stepping
outside on Thursdays like come on I mean
then you're gonna get some like creepy
old guy who's gonna be like do that
yeah I grew up here the picture of
Richard Fleet no because the precogs
can't see a thing you know that you know
minority minority report yeah yeah I
like that movie it's cool but yeah that
reform you know has to happen on both
sides you know for it to work not just
on the screener side but the people
implementing it in the government side
have to be trained on how to do that the
right way and not put Tim Poole on a
waiting list because he's Deadpool I
like you know in that movie Minority
Report I like the idea of pre-crime I
don't like how they executed it if
somebody was going to commit a murder in
that movie you get life in prison
basically they put you in this thing and
they put you in a tube or whatever it's
like dude if someone's going to commit a
crime you stop it and then say we can
tell if you're going to do it again and
then they won't
in the movie most of it was passion
people losing their cool and there was
almost no premeditated murder because
they had precogs psychics who could
basically see if you were going to
commit a murder but then they would come
in and like tag you and then drag you
away and be like you're done even if you
didn't commit a crime it's like if you
can dispatch a crew to stop the murder
from happening congratulations now it's
like it was a passion murder we could
don't do it and if the person is going
to do it again you can see it and you
can prevent it so like anyway good movie
though good movie
let's grab some more super jets Vic says
not many people talk about the
specificity of the profile of a school
shooter absent father childhood trauma
social isolation and pharmaceutical
drugs yeah
yep that's conversation number one
fatherlessness Matt Walsh had a whole
thread about it yeah fatherless list uh
well just a profile of a school shoot I
think he was pretty much on target wow
so it seems to be the case huh so Matt
Walsh interviewed uh David Hogg
did you say Matt Walsh interviewed him
did I say Matt Walsh yeah yeah oh who
did I I didn't mean Matt Walsh I meant
uh the other guy because in a video you
said Matt Walsh he's a corporate shell
and someone was like why is Tim calling
Matt Walsh
confused oh man I am so sorry Matt I did
not mean that about you I was talking
about the other guy what's his name uh I
can't remember I want to see the
interview why did I say Matt Walsh man
I'm sorry dude I'm so sorry Matt Walsh
you corporate Jessica no it's that other
guy who was a republican but then hated
Donald Trump and that's something I
don't know maybe I said Matt Walsh
not from the Eagles oh no Matt I owe you
uh a beer or slime out Matt you got to
come on the show fly out the one back to
Nashville I said that here too nobody
corrected me well I thought it was real
but I'm glad I brought it up no you were
like oh Matt Walsh and I was like I was
like wait I guess I looked it up too and
I was like what I just it's you know
what it is it's that Matt well she's so
much more relevant than Joe is I know
right I just couldn't think of a guy who
didn't matter
sincerely apologize for saying that man
I did not mean that I should I got to
put a correction on that video I did not
mean that got to figure out which one
that was
all right cold Deluxe production says
Tim if you want a gun law expert on talk
to the armed scholar who was educated in
laws and discuss his laws and lawsuits
around gun rights he'd love to come on
the show well let's take a look into
them we will write down his name armed
scholar got it
we're gonna have to fly out Mash yeah
I must be too tired no it's because I
was I'm now mixing Matt with cash and
now going sideways
I pulled the Biden game over you did it
be the next president you know next time
buying gas I'm gonna have to be like
well it happened to the best of us love
you Joe
Joe Biden or Joe Walsh oh yeah both both
all right why is this YouTube freezing
on me
Ben sprink says the force of law cannot
be used on a citizen unless they do
something illegal this has to change for
a mentally ill person when it is known
that a person is mentally ill they
should be separated from society and
given help gun laws are useless yeah but
Define mentally ill and what kind of
mentally ill that's that's tough man
right yeah
everyone's saying Tim is Joe Biden I
admit it I I got I could never criticize
the man again next time he says
something like Trinity pressure I'm just
going to be like well you know that
Walsh was right Matt Walsh
all right what is this uh
Iggy the incubus says Tim and Curry what
advice do you have for smaller creators
who have an interest in discussing these
topics so that we can make more Avenues
and wheel houses for honest to good
faith discussions use Rumble yeah new
networks and Truth social and Truth you
get in early on these new networks and
you can meet a lot of cool people true
social is powered by Rumble oh that's
right that's right yep there you go
there you go man
all right Kevin Clark says if you
defended anyone who rioted you don't get
to say on gun control if people who
don't understand guns can pass
legislation on guns men can do the same
for abortion y'all keep up the good work
there you go man
Patricia Swisher says 13 states allow
non-citizens to vote look it up yeah
how do we not get ripped apart if you've
got states that allow non-citizens to
vote no I don't know man
all right we can grab a couple more we
got so many
all right Carpe dongtum says thanks for
saying it Tim for saying which one
I'm not sure Trevor Matt Walsh thing
Trevor ritzke says speaking of Magic the
Gathering have you seen how the game is
so complex you can literally make a
touring complete computer can you do
that really
I'm wondering if like I didn't see what
was going on because in my video I said
Matt Walsh instead of Joe Walsh and then
a bunch of people probably sent it to
him and he was probably like what I'm
sure he's like what is going on right
now I'm feeling my best but if you look
it up I'm sure Matt knew Joe Walsh
interviewed him and he went no no no
other wall I'm surprised nobody emailed
me about it he they've commented on my
Instagram and I was like what on Earth
are they talking about I thought I'm
just losing oh people were yeah I was
like wow
It's just sometimes it's just I pull a
Biden you know said the wrong name we
all do oh I feel so bad about that
everyone tell everyone tell Matt that
I'm sorry
we like Matt Walsh I love them all right
that's cool yeah
um
Ryan Culkin says at this point the
government should just legalize an
annual Purge Night
people love those movies though
I never watched it I've not watched a
single Purge movie you got to watch it
you got to watch at least one maybe the
first one
yeah okay
you haven't seen either cast
which one's the best one first one okay
that's what I'm going there you go
all right sir Lemongrab says Tim how do
you feel about 3D printing uh with metal
I would say unacceptable
but that's just for your name in reality
no it's pretty cool
um I watched a video I think they use
lasers and it was like metal dust or
something and then it like 3D printed an
object it's like not very strong I don't
know something yeah it super heats the
dust and then melts it and reforms is
that how it works I'm pretty sure yeah
wow that's crazy that's cool it's a lot
of potential ladies and gentlemen if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
let Matt Walsh know I'm very sorry for
using his name incorrectly when I was
talking about Joe head over to
timcast.com become a member subscribe uh
we are going to have a members only show
coming up at 11 or so p.m you can follow
the show at timcast IRL you can follow
me personally everywhere at timcast cash
you want to shout anything out uh thanks
for having me the book please buy the
plot against the king it's the number
one children's book in America adults
can learn about Russia gate while
teaching their kids you're gonna love it
the truth matters that's what the whole
purpose of the book is thanks for having
me back on the show where do people buy
it uh go to either the plot against the
king.com or check out fightwithcash.com
all the information is there get a copy
I signed 4 000 over the weekend so we're
keeping we're going
yeah thanks for having me on the show I
really appreciate it brother and uh for
anybody wants to follow me you can do so
at Adrian Norman DC on all the old
platforms Twitter Facebook Instagram Etc
um on the newer platforms like true
social just Adrian Norman and uh we can
duke it out on online all right are you
in Crossing you guys thank you so much
for coming cash Adrian love you guys man
it's great to see you again dude good to
meet you finally for the first time well
eventually you're gonna finally we meet
and I wanted to tell everyone I was on
pop culture crisis today episode 127 uh
it's youtube.com I think it's probably
just search pop culture crisis on
YouTube You're gonna find it pop culture
crisis wonderful that is always a good
time I've been filling in every
Wednesday for them and it's always a
blast it's a kind of a feel that I don't
usually get into so we talk about a lot
of cultural stuff great time and real
quick pop culture crisis when you Super
Chat money guns yeah it's fired yeah
unbelievably distracting and uh the
stink bugs and the money flying through
the air it's really one went in my
coffee it was hilarious good time one of
the moneys went in my car oh one of the
20s that's better than a stink bug the
next step is going to be to have uh oh
they did the parties today yeah so once
once a certain number of Super attaches
super chats get reached on pop culture
crisis lights go off add money guns
crazy yeah we're talking about having
some music and like things flying by
behind me as it's on I mean nuts okay
that just sounds a little distracting
anyway it is a great time if you guys
want to check out pop culture crisis
they are also on YouTube Brett works
very hard on that and it's going to be
awesome in the future you guys may
follow me on Twitter and minds.com at
Sarah patchlitz as well as
sarahpatchlets.me we will see you all
over at timcast.com for that members
segment thanks for hanging out bye guys